une production du studio sfr
[Musique]
nous sans filtre le podcast où on parle
ce qu'on veut nous inviter dans cette
super contente avec moins d'une plante
cette semaine on avait on avait dit on
avait promis qu'on allait faire
c'est une promesse
on avait dit qu'on allait faire des pas
de casse sur les élections aujourd'hui
c'est la première partie deux parties
tout à fait aujourd'hui on reçoit et
yannick dufresne qui politologue qui
professeur en sciences politiques à
l'université laval qui en découlent
quart d'heure de mutiler boussole
électorale ou si le data goodship
observe canal sous sa peau c'est quoi
c'est c'est sur le site de radio canada
vous faites ça vous répondent à des
questions puis ça vous situe sur
l'échiquier électoral des différents
partis ou est-ce que vous situez avec
quels partis veulent plus d'affinités
pis le data gucci c'est en un peu
contraire répondre à des questions ceux
qui ont rien à voir rien à voir ta
politique et
ou prenez votre café quel genre de
musique que vous écoutez ça prédit en
fait ça selon votre profil ça va peut
prédire ou qui vous avez vite et qui
dans mon cas c'était assez proche de la
haine il ya next est vraiment fascinant
fera reparler beaucoup du du
comportement électoral a fait qu'est-ce
qui fait qu'une personne vote pour tel
ou tel parti et puis tout est question
identitaire avec cet outil questions
d'environnement qui ont un effectif de
toutes les questions vrai que c'est
vraiment super intéressant puis aussi
qu'est ce qui fait qu'ils sont les
stratégies utilisées par les partis pour
rejoindre
des potentiels électeurs
c'est vraiment fascinant de parler aussi
bien sûr de la campagne en coop de faire
partie des propositions petit prix mais
surtout si plus largement des
du comportement des électeurs finalement
finir m'a fasciné je pense vous à
l'adresse web une affaire aussi de celle
d'adam dans ce cas unique est à la base
de plusieurs outils qui permettent de
simplifier les élections simplifier les
offres politiques qui lobe sur
l'altération d'un très bon pied à la fin
du podcast on mentionne que c'est
vraiment important de s'informer
d'emploi et pas de recette secrète le
pour essayer de sortir d'un pattern de
d'élections et générationnelle
puis pour être normalement être en
faisant un électoral personnellement
j'ai réalisé que j'étais vraiment
vraiment plus de propositions de plus de
parties que je croyais qu'ils me
rejoignait fait que c'est intéressant de
se poser vraiment la question c'est de
faire d'établir des valeurs en fonction
de ce que les parties ont à offrir on
vous encourage à vous informer si on
vous encourage à aller se permet de
dépolitiser
des fois on fait ce genre d'affaires de
l'exercice lui comme d'hab spectrale ou
contre qui on s'aperçoit qu'ils écrire
maquis baisse que je pratique était noir
blanc c'est pas tendre or blanc qui a
crime scene tel parti que je pensais
qu'ils étaient le diable en personne
j'ai sur quelques points les affinités
avec ces remous choses en perspective ça
ça nous rappelle que
les projets voilà que la vérité se
trouve dans à fait délicieux compétences
tout est toujours plus complexe qu'on
tente
bondée que le podcast de cette semaine
et présenté par nos amis chez mindscape
même skate c'est la compagnie par
excellence pour l'entretien de la peau
des poils des eaux de la pilosité de des
odeurs
c'est ma compagnie de de soins pour la
peau préféré moi j'utilise le shampoing
et le body wash à tous tout me douche
puis le jeudi tous les chalets dire tous
les jours mais audrey que je prends une
douche à tous les jours pendant presque
tous les jours et pas tous les jours des
foyers des jo et escape la douche et
j'en ai marre des journées de leur odeur
caractéristique mindscape est incroyable
lyon l'odeur parfois dans des eaux dans
tout les produits
le will we work - chaque gros fan du
lido à que j'aime ce ça c'est en fait
c'est pau c'est pour la gestion des
poils de nez des poils des
fois par semaine m un petit coup louis
walker pour garder sa béquille moi
j'aime pas à aborder les poils de nez
qui dépasse trop personnellement
surveillance d'un gaulois que jamais
ceux ci n'ont pas le fameux la pièce
maîtresse si vous voulez de m'inscrire
c'est le langoureux là on est rendu au
quatrième édition la mort 4.0 c'est tout
simplement le meilleur envol historique
que vous allez jamais utilisée
heward pauvres pour l'ami dans la douche
j'ai vraiment
il restait rien espagne et dans des
technologies qui protège la peau aussi
cette confiance est idéal c dr on a un
code promo pour vous pour tous les
produits indique est tout le package
qu'on a devant nous à les voir sur leur
site note que pense le sans filtre pour
20% le rabais puis le shipping gratuit
ce qui est considéré avec mercy masqué
rouyère brouillette
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ben voilà c'est ça
aussi j'ai fait la littérature aussi
fade away
histoire et lettres rien fait moi j'ai
commencé 1-1
en gestion d'entreprise en sciences
humaines profil de gestion entreprise
non mais ouais j'ai fait une situation
là dedans dans mon cou ramener fille
c'était le cours de français ont pu
france est un genre devraient mener les
courbes gâteau au cégep dans le fond tu
te demande vraiment de tous les champs
d'intérêt puis c'est dumont vraiment ça
fait chier les cours obligatoires
d'isigny moi je te colle aussi dans la
course et jacques et mon cours de
français en c'est montcourt préférer la
maire session sécher pour complèter fois
qu'il ya peut-être quelque chose de
finalement jeter les chutes chez les
profs ils étaient dans quel département
comment j'ai commencé mon c est un droit
des affaires jean ray à nice puis au
bout du bout des landes choisi vous
savez séoul où nancy 15e de la ligue
arabe youssef qu'est-ce qui est pas
j'ai haï sauf que c'est pour ça que jal
en arts visuels au début je finis un cas
sur le terrain installation à moi si
c'est ça le monde mais c'est le jv remet
en
question la vie
j'aime être faite jusque dans leur
cinéma ou la littérature française à
l'uqam évidemment dans le temps en fait
j'ai reçu comme un formulaire puis on
l'envoyait de mumbai a dit je trouverais
ça demain matin je me serais même à
versailles et mathématicien et
informaticien drogués que je sais moi
jusqu'à moi j'entendais les fidèles de
l'animation vidéo ou des trucs comme ça
j'échange mon premier chercheur en
informatique appliquée ainsi j'ai sorti
que nominal je pourrais je le finis
tripes et je
veux que tu m'as balancé
je change plus les chalands sciences po
que le financer plus tard que
l'informatique ses revenus
aujourd'hui je suis en social numérique
4k de mons évite
la vie fait bien les choses quand tu
fais confiance
d'accord on a commencé
merci à
tous les films qu'on verra jamais
réserve qu'on ait de l'année mais
quand même j'avoue que j'ai de moins en
moins de temps depuis que je suis prof
pour écouter des films noirs j'aimerais
le commun je pense et cyril sont moins
c'est le cognitive - à suivre
là on va aussi de regarder plus ils ont
l'air du temps mais je t'ai signifie
dans dans leur maison dans l'application
potes
mais j'ai fait appel au cégep l'ont pas
fait j'écoutais crime un film projet
aurait coûté les j'avais regardé la les
150 meilleurs films de mdb le jeu
l'avaient descendue au complet pendant
mes deux ans et j'ai bien apprécié une
fois que tu as fait ça il ya encore
beaucoup beaucoup de films à écouter
déjà bien dans les films mais sauf
qu'une fois que tu as fait c'est un bon
bagage type le genre dont se retrouve à
écouter vraiment moins de films mais
quand même une culture cinématographique
quand même assez développés ne s'est pas
alors cet exercice le cgtsim analyste de
mb
c'est là que je réalise il ya quand même
des anomalies il ya des films des fois
qu'ils sortent en route ce genre je peux
pas croire que j'en reviens à la charge
en culotte chaîne c'est un bon film est
déjà numéro 2 après da costa rica 2-1
meilleur film de tous les symboles
savons faire
merci pourquoi que je compense parce que
c'est la seule façon quand j'étais en
ontario que les gens qui savaient bien
prononcé mon nom c'est frais c'est quand
tu prends de france ni le personnage de
catherine the french vous avez déjà lu
la motion
ces malades mais c'est la cendre est ce
qu'il sait à l'accent du maupuy dumas ce
domaine
c'est drôle que ça ça va joint pour mon
expertise sondages mais c'est vrai que
comme un billet d'analystes du mbd sur
les films récents ce soir ils vont
attirer les vieux changement paul think
and il bouge pas le titre phare de
change pas mais des fois quelqu'un un
nouveau film qui sort comme inception il
ya comme un un boost avec justin coupe
de chine qui sait pas qu'elle soit c'est
avec le même état de 250 meilleurs sims
arvier
cobp en préparation au podcast on a fait
la boussole électorale on a fait le data
goetschy pis c'est incroyable c'est
incroyable explique nous défendre et ça
c'est fait
puisque tu as participé à la co-création
vous allez commençons avec son pied puis
partout mais pas fait oui et puis après
vous allez voir plus que le
développement de data gachi directement
lié aux quais développement de l'islam
seulement connaissez cette date à
gautschi j'avais pas entendu mais
j'étais on est étudiant en instaurant
puis j'avais comme d'autres d'autres de
mes collègues louis étudiant des
dotations aux doctorants et donc les
ventes de linden qui professeur gregory
10 à copenhague à ce moment puis on
s'est rencontré la botte le cliff y
avait eu six des leurs et sexy temple
lot il y avait des trucs utiliser le
numérique pour essayer de vulgariser la
comaga accueilli vous avez dit ce sera
compliqué la politique c'est comment
est-ce qu'on peut simplifier ça c'est
vrai que quand on veut positionner parce
politique mais l'idéologie c'est vrai
cela dit comment est ce qu'on peut
vraiment simplifié au maximum tout en
donnant une information c'est supposer
que la puce électorale offre des
dimensions puis moi je t'ai spéciales et
déjà deux sondages étaient déjà les
données en plus mais c'est à toronto que
les francophones en plus je connais
c'est la réalité du québec celle du
canada anglais que rapidement j'a été
minable dans le projet visait au départ
c'est vraiment un truc d'engagement pour
vraiment mme amener les jeunes à
s'insérer sa politique
reste à la maison pour utiliser le
numérique pour pouvoir atteindre ces
gens là pour faire du transfert de
connaissances sur comment qu'on peut
positionner les partis politiques puis
les plateformes puis sur un an et un
jour je commence je relisais
compliqué c'est compliqué il ya beaucoup
de détails que se demander comment ce
qu'on peut kadri
ses lecteurs comment qu'on fait
tranquillement des sacs a précédemment
liés avec radio-canada cbi si on les
rencontre et présenter le projet et ont
marqué oui on nouveaux partenaires de
notre côté mais est ce qu on vous
faisait les sondages à chaque fois
contraint de pousser lectorale 60 100
questions
avec des comités scientifiques pour
choisissez quoi les enjeux les plus
importants
ensuite on fait des sondages on fait des
analyses dimensionnelle pour vraiment
retirer à les deux principales
dimensions perdre aussi de pouvoir
positionner les partis politiques les
partis politiques participent la plupart
du temps maintenant qu'on est connu au
début cette fois ci
s'avère un peu spécial comme projet
menace et c'est drôle à quel point ils
étaient 2 mais l'on sait la première
dont 11 ans à quel point que ça a évolué
puisque au début c'était vraiment
considérer innovateur c'est la cas
maintenant analyser le finaliser que le
sol et les classes tout le monde
connaissait put finalement mais on
demande aux partis politiques maintenant
de participer moi je la vis cela comme
une plateforme interactive le souvent
les gens que ce rappel absolue terrasses
les deux dimensions ouais mais nous
avons fait mais donc pour pour la note
que si socio-économique fake de droite
ou de gauche puis identitaire c'est
intéressant quand même parce que c'est
seulement que je sais pas si vous saviez
mais la miss électoral le premier à
sauter haut sur les élections de 2011 au
fédéral mais c'est ensuite le fait
l'ontario en fait les états unis et
cloud jeunes ont tout appris et après la
la on le fait au québec qui faisait mal
fait dans différentes provinces
canadiennes on le fait tous en
australie où est-ce que par capita
l'absolu est là où est-ce que c'est plus
populaires c'est en nouvelle zélande
pourtant promis reste l australie puis
québec égale canada mais on le fait
aussi en allemagne au brésil oublie
souvent les endroits maintenant être
différents endroits mais la seule place
où est-ce que c'est pas social gauche
droite puis chalmé gorges what is ok ou
est ce qu une dimension identitaire une
dimension identitaire qui est importante
au québec on n'a pas le choix la prendre
en considération puis moi je dis souvent
c'est à dire plusieurs types qui existe
maintenant mais au canada comme
ethiquable de faire un succès comme ça
que l'abc électorale ces concerts ont
tous été forcé à cause de la nature du
pays à pousser plus loin notre réflexion
sur les dimensionnalité parce que pour
faire rentrer le québec avec le reste du
canada diamonds mois sont symboliques
divorce est idéologique plutôt
il fallait avoir une réflexion qui émet
sur la méthode on est obligé d'aller
plus loin fellah l'indépendance du
québec ce que c'est de gauche de droite
ça dépend qui tue par la redevance
maxima exactement exactement donc il
fallait trouver des méthodes pour voir t
c est ce qui t au québec sur un trade
centre l'eau je suis dans le temps du
moins le jeu déjà parce que nous sommes
avec le parti québécois
mais dans ris canada les jeunes sont
capables des dépenses québec c'est des
gens de très droite - oui il ya des
circonscriptions en alberta sont plus
là
mettant souvent sur twitter tu vois pas
ces études et dudu du québec bashing
quand même assez assez grossier laitiers
puis des fois je me pose la question
même si elle un référendum
canadien sur l'indépendance du québec
pétanque irait même plus de chances que
l'indépendance québec réussissent
je comprend d'où est-ce que tu proviens
excellent selon les sondages est ou non
mais y'a des gens qui sont en faveur des
dépenses québec pour dire
dans l'ouest ça dans le temps j'en
appelle parce que c'est puis dans le
saut d'obstacles en aussi tiges comme je
disais ça commençait un peu comme un
outil d'engagement moi je t'aurais
spéciale de des sondages je tripais sous
les chiffres sodi gonzesses c'est de
donner leurs salariés du sommet comme on
s'attendait moi je m'attendais après
environ
50000 utilisateurs
puisque les je me rappelle un cas que
dans les femmes savantes vraiment
vendeur travail nous on vise un million
de
2 millions en
2011 voilà qui fait la première à vie
suite en partant du mignon mais ça a été
difficile parce que quand on lance un
projet comme ça
fesse des fois c'est ça qui est un grand
un petit toutes les frasques du logiciel
toute la réflexion tout les travaille
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de gens sont
différentes dans différentes expertises
ensemble dit très très difficile
d'attaquer c'est la même chose si l'ap
les autres projets que j'ai fait aussi
au début les serveurs étaient pas fait
pour se lancer jeudi comment on les sert
à planter avec quelques petits bugs des
gens qui se plaignent aussi que le texte
est biaisée des cas la grippe les
libéraux
défi principal c'est de faire une
plateforme qui complètement impartial
qui va pas amener du monde c'est juste
et justine de 1 % des billets ça fait
quand même différence en bout de ligne
c'est une très grande responsabilité
mais s'est senti dès le départ mais au
début c'était que mon projet d'étudiants
latéraux de
profondeur sur le comité scientifique du
sommet mais à la fin des étudiants puis
on a joué dans les ligues majeures avec
radio canada on voyait site de l'actuel
numéro 1 sur twitter on s'entendait pas
et en même temps je pense que rappeler
de sun media comme un taux de quebecor
un peu l'équivalent foxnews non piratés
dans les journées le sun sea puis sortez
et il y en a nous chaque jour
de jouer c'est sur exactement exactement
exactement donc comment qu'on ait réagi
puisque je suis retenu le directeur
d'école obsolète terral parti mais je te
ferai je te francophone ici donc je pars
les deux langues puis je dire rapidement
sur ce qu'ils vont me les faut défendre
comment qu'on défend sommet avec la
science donc on a construit toute la
méthodologie encore aujourd'hui dans les
succès de la beauce électorale la
méthodologie est ouverte les gens
peuvent lire puis j'avoue que les gens
et puis je répondais le retour mais
n'altèrent 2011 2012 2014 au québec le
cancer au québec je pense que chaque
fois quelqu'un disait le mot buzz sur
twitter
lakota que c'est bon on est toujours
ouvert à des critiques constructives
voici notre méthodologie sur une
contacter quand il y en a déjà l'un des
consultations on est obligé de pousser
tout ça parce que finalement à la fin
c'est vrai que si la guette et quand je
dis tout à l'heure et au canada c'était
difficile de faire intégrer tout le
monde si on dément mais c'est pas de
gauche pas de droit commun qu'on le fait
vite et pour que ça ait une convergence
de l'ensemble comprenait six ans donc
j'ai long à développer vraiment l'alluré
pour l'améliorer aussi après jusqu'à un
point et en 2015 je pense qu'on avait
même intégrer leurs trois dimensions la
seule place au clair au monde que vous
cela pourrait perdre une troisième
dimension c'est durant les élections
fédérales
parce que justement parce que là pour
fêter un peu le québec dans toutes ses
dimensions là mais quelque chose
d'important c'est que ce cas quelqu'un
de qualité ces données là quand vous
avez sa fille de la valeur je me suis
fait on a un truc j'ai dû me soit une
carte temps en temps ça peut aussi faire
c'est qu'aujourd'hui dans les cartes le
barça conscription jimmy par jour on
voyait la bagarre
il a les mains le québécois quand le mât
s'effondrer le fils on a fait du chemin
que ce
genre de time lapse oui exactement et
gio aplon le métier je pense qu'ils
étaient encore sur youtube d'ailleurs
communs ou est ce qu'on voyait un vidéo
jour par jour de l'évolution par
circonscription plus envoyer qu'on
l'amène plus à orange c'est là orange
québec il vient de tarente de ces
données là nous ont permis de publier
après des articles scientifiques comme
par exemple si on parle souvent c'est
les journalistes puis tout ça c'est
normal mais on interprète qu'est ce qui
se passait autour de nous mais avec des
données probantes de l'effet jack layton
à tout le monde en parle c'est difficile
afin qu'on ne pas les donner mais on
avait des données tellement compliqué de
voir l'effet grand de las
palmas où la semaine après la présence
de jack layton à tout le monde en parle
mais c'est notre maison le fait après
l'élection ce condiment l'élection c'est
la guerre totale n'est pas vraiment le
temps de faire trop d' analyse n'a
appris que l'on s'est rendu compte de la
richesse de ces données là aussi
c'était dans le cadre d'une diversité
avec ses biceps
donc à passer mais comment est-ce qu'on
peut se donner durant la campagne
pouvoir faire des histoires pouvoir
montrer ces données loeb ça fait partie
aussi de l'information quantique à
donner des données limitées à ce que ce
programme d'échantillonnage à
allaiter c'est comme un conte propreté
comme un comble quand j'ai le billet tu
te reste que l'échantillonnage c'est
pathétique en fait la belle étoile
on s'est demandé qui est quelles parties
on pense voter veille
la tendance vous la voyez vraiment
évolué au fur et mesure que vous donnez
j'imagine sont quand même très nettement
les gens qui font ce que vous avez quand
même l'échantillon de finalement
beaucoup plus grand qu'un sondage
oui mais mais faut faire attention c'est
pas le nombre d'utilisateurs où le
nombre de personnages aux sondages qui
qui qui peut redonner
sa valeur qu'est ce qu'on appelle une
valeur référentiel des sommets ce qu'on
peut partir d'un échantillon alors faire
une généralisation sur la population
absolument que de marques classiques
sait plus vraiment mais on choisit un
échantillon de manière aléatoire quand
le marais à tour mais ça jamais été de
qu'on n'ait jamais d'écarts et de faire
ce que tu quelqu'un qui habite être seul
il ya plus de chances de stades
sélectionnés 2010 soit plus que quelques
habite avec neuf colloque s'étant même
cadence hier au téléphone fixe et il ya
toujours eu besoin de corriger les
données lan ce moment il ya beaucoup de
gens qui répondent pas aux sondages du
rush mais quand même dont ils font qu
est ce qu on appelle la triste
ratification empressé d'aller chercher
des couches de la population aime ses
lecteurs on appelle ça comment les
sondages que les gens surtout qu'elle
est suffisamment élevé exactement pis
mais ils sont m ils ont à cent mille
personnes mais qu'un billet vraiment
systématique dont les anglophones
suspends ton truc parce que je sais ton
armé je serai pokhara de coeur j'espère
qu'on abuse électoral qu'est ce qui nous
permettait de faire ce qu'on avait
tellement de répondants qui ont été
capables d'aller chercher la personne de
mener à réviser en abitibi poser les
questions les récessions pour des
questions variées scénographique tasse
on corrige en fonction de recensement
appelée plein de ce traité et il ya
toute une littérature sur les
pondérations statistiques via mail
absolue terral c'était vraiment un bon
c'est comme les mouches à fruits
comment un bon bassin pour pouvoir
tester différents pondération passe pas
fini le mot jamais étudions c'est
comment et quand même terminer sa
maîtrise justement sur la correction du
biais de sélection dans les sondages
obtiennent
ces fascinants pour qui ça donne quand
même
même même c'était les questions sont
somme toute
simple c'est ça permet d'aider pas
obligé de prendre
position définie ce temps nos pauvres
puis ça donne un résultat de chez nous
on le fait les deux
dans les derniers jours puis
c'est fou comment
tous les pains tous les prêts par
presque tous les partis mais ton peuvent
répondre à certaines de tes de tes
préoccupations c'est nous on est tombé
pieusement même place que c'est sans se
parler on est tombé quasiment paiera
même aulas mais genre et qui distant de
quatre parties alors que si tu me
demande à moi maintenant qu'elles
pensent changer pour x ou y participent
c'est plus clair que wes que je suis tu
es fait que c'est là qu'on réalise
maintenant que les partis on connaît pas
tout ce qu'ils ont à offrir on ne sait
où le pack nous tous qui promettent par
exemple on a vraiment des billets envers
les parties
se soient plus important c'est les
limites de l'absolu lectorat l'absolu
chorale prend une position normale sinon
censure que c'est un jugement
salle une volonté well à l'aps
électorale le buste outre prédit votre
vote les but c'est de montrer où se
situer par rapport aux enjeux papa aux
anges c'est très très important parce
que lt à tout le monde que les gens
votent pas nécessairement sur les enjeux
il ya plein de raisons de ne pas voter
pour le parti qui est plus paul était en
jeu je vends ses traditions partisans de
socialiser à être un républicain
démocrate un pays qui soit libéral était
donc ce sont des raisons les gens qui
ont des prêts à priori comme dit mais
aussi
les gens peuvent
peuvent simplement ne pas faire
confiance aux partis dont plus après ça
c'est une autre affaire
il y avait des éléments aussi plus
stratégique et j'étais quand même pas
très convoité où on veut plus voter pour
un parti ce qui a plus de chances de
gagner donc c'est la vérité d'une montre
ou est-ce que vous situer par rapport à
pisa aussi ça prend aussi part pourrait
qu'il est le postulat c'est que les gens
ont des attitudes sur ces enjeux là
c'est ça puis drake justin en jeu est ce
que ces trente questions de table
certains peut-être un de ces enjeux le
kivu vrm en plus important ça n'a
l'habitude on les prend en considération
vous êtes capable de pondérer vos
positions sur chacun d argent en
fonction de votre importance que vous
avez aussi pour l'autre élément qu'il
faut faire attention aussi à capter et à
une simplification de la réalité mais
qui est commune donc c'est les deux
dimensions qu'on montre sont les
dimensions les plus communes dans
société on utilise avec des sondages
donc c'est pas nous qui décidons les
dimensions c'est même pas les parties
d'absolu tracer les gens parce qu'on
fait des sondages c'est les dimensions
qui sont les plus communes mais après
quelques mais que c'était les dimensions
go droite décision parce que c'est des
corrélations décolérait son jeu l'un des
exemples ceci dans les
laits le conservatisme moral sympa à
réfléchir mais souvent les gens qui sont
pour le mariage gay mais ces mêmes
personnes qui sont pour l'avortement
plus que ces mêmes personnes qui sont
contre la peine de mort c'est des trucs
comme ça pose la question mais pourquoi
est ce que ces gens mais c'est ça si je
dirais comme des corrélations comme ça
que quand il fait des analyses
dimensionnelle dès qu'apple allait
sortir ce qu'on soit si ce mot raciste
du gauche droite mais par contre il ya
des gens qui peuvent être je peux moi
je mets l'exemple l'environnement puis
l'avortement c'est jésus comme ça le met
ensemble souvent les gens qui sont
contre pour l'avortement mais ces mêmes
personnes qui sont environnementalistes
pour la question métier déjà imputées
aux partis va comme une évidence en même
temps c'est le pourquoi charles pour
expliquer mais c'est sain naisse et des
structures idéologiques puissant une
trace aussi la douce m'ont ainsi de
comprendre mais c'est une même
fascination première c'est de comprendre
pour les gens associent pourquoi comment
ça évolue ça évolue dans le temps si ça
vaut lui même parmi des sous-groupes de
ya des gens je pense que l'ancien chef
du parti vert elizabeth may cry et peine
j'ai lu qu'elle est peut-être revenir
mais je pense qu'ils écoutent peut-être
[Rires]
mais elle et jeudi a été très très
chaude à l'idée l'avortement si je
l'aimais et puis je les attends
environnementalistes
qui jamais parlé c'est sur le terme tant
pour les droits des animaux de ce jeudi
comme cadre de voir le lien qui aime le
faire comme il ya des gens peuvent
associer pourquoi l'immigration et
l'environnement mais en même temps à des
gens qui peuvent être moins pour une
création aux candidats mais ça augmente
les avions et tout et tout et tout et
tout mais et puis repartir je pense
qu'au danemark justement que devenu
super environnementalistes mais moins
pour les migrations
massives le goût de plusieurs personnes
ces gens là peuvent avoir une cohérence
qu'avant quelqu'un qu'on disait on
n'était pas dans les deux dimensions
mais ça peut être de l'incohérence que
ce qui existe beaucoup dans la tête on
le voyait des gens qui ont passé
l'information politique n'est pas
satisfaisant politiques pour organiser
leurs idées mais moi j'ai passé de 10 on
la trouve peut-être même mais présentent
ces gens ils peuvent avoir une réflexion
mais qui est plus marginale plus pour
l'abc lectorale ça marche un peu moins
bien se livre à une convergence de la
santé c'est pour ça que le cas vous
regarde et alex électorale il ya un
autre graphique en haut à droite avec
des bars ça c'est les renards est
complètement le postulat de bi
dimensionnalité idéologique blond les
chacun des enjeux comme par le plan
contribue et par lui même ce donc qu'un
incohérente en le résultat que vous avez
dans la 2 dans les deux dimensions dans
le café cabaret est justement de tête
une réflexion 10 ou plus marginale que
que la partie conventionnelle
ce qui doit rester ont parlé la semaine
passée on a fait un podcast juste les
deux tipis ou vont répondre à des
questions puis la question je te demande
sur les élections puis sur le sur le
vote il est venu de ces puits ont parlé
à quel point
ses traits
ce triste dans titeuf j'ai l'impression
que le parti auquel tu as ce site sebi
souvent ça devient une cause du père
séparé motifs python tel parti ça
devient des grâce aux ventes elles
partent ici opposé cesser les arbres à
personne c'est caca réalité évidemment
c'est beaucoup plus beaux complexes que
ce type i c'est même dans nos
discussions kit espagne au racing qui
était
comprenais pas vraiment partie à part
dire c'est que somme toute avait
peut-être un parti auquel nous on
s'identifiait mon petit juste pour ceux
ci on s'est fait insulter un commentaire
on a fourché du monde c'est fou comme
encaisser ça vient chercher justement
faisant la boussole électorale qui est
intéressant c'est que
la boussole électorale sont fous ltée à
quelle partie du densifie tipi
ça donne des résultats finalement qui
s'est acquis tels partis que je pensais
qu'ils étaient vraiment à pau
moi dans mon sac dans l'environnement
c'est pas nécessairement la chose avec
laquelle j'ai une dent team et crème
sauter leur jeu tombe pile sur lui payer
quelqu'un qui prescrit quelque chose de
précis confrontant là dedans dès lé
jeudi des affinités etc etc c'est parce
que je pensais qu était le 10e but
allemand crime là dessus comment se
jetant à corps avec les autres et puis
ça remet les choses en perspective ça on
dirait que ça nous la paix avec la
politique
cccc s'éloigne lentement non absolument
tout ça c'est important aussi parce que
ça vient des côtes est des états unis
lala
l'identification partisane c'est très
très fort puis un processus depuis
dernière des cyniques six produits tout
encore une fois littérature qui se
développe là dessus sur la le conseil de
polarisation les parties seraient de
plus en plus de faire ce qui concerne la
polarisation effective qu'est ce que tu
viens de mentionner que les gens
détestent plus de plus en plus l'autre
partie s'il ya un concept n'en fais là
dedans puis ça aussi ça m'intéresse de
savoir d'où est-ce que c'est après ce
que ces avis c'est ce côté lopy pas les
gens ont besoin de s'identifier quelque
chose est sûre on va chercher les
valeurs profondes nécessairement c'est
de la politique le dis comme c'est un
peu normal qu'ils aient des débats c'est
sûr pas de débat dispose avec on parle
de polarisation
clapper la relation se fait dans le
respect mais c'est la démocratie la
normale les gens commencent à des tests
et les autres puis à écouter les autres
peut-être là que ça devient un peu
malsain
comme si je peux quelqu'un de très
partisan je pense que c'est un élément
politique qui m'inquiète puis que je
m'attaquais c'est la polarisation c'est
le multi comme la boussole ou là ou data
gachi s'attaque directement c'est de
comprendre des poussées se dit bien que
moi j'apprécie et le prêt à porter un an
dans les vêtements n'étaient pour éviter
le prêt à penser
une fois c'est en plus c'est puis on a
ri plomb des voix là on rentre dans
année 4,4 dans les projets du sommet
c'est extrêmement complexe et je fais ça
je peux le spécialiste des plateformes
électorales jeudi jetant un
politiser les plateformes ya des
surprises il ya toujours des surprises
faut aller voir faut s'informer puissent
ils sont votre on s'informe on va se
rendre compte que des fois le caire 4
qu'elle colle pas toujours
c'est un peu que ça soit des partis
politiques c'est pour simplifier pour
simplifier aussi une tragédie comme un
évidemment le tout le monde puisse pas
un truc de mépris doucement dans une
bulle de pultusk aux attaques ont fait
des sondages l'information politique la
certification pour les très très très
très basse les gens s'intéressent pas
tant pour ses tissus en général on peut
toujours faire mieux mais en même temps
je m'intéresse pas tant un truc à part
ça on pourrait dire oui mais de la
démocratie oui je comprends et je le
comprends totalement maintenant les gens
sont occupés sauf que les partis
politiques peuvent représenter quand
même un élément un raccourci décisionnel
comme un élément la base il faut donner
de la bonne information puis d'être
ouverts puis de voir comment ce que
chacun d d d d informations peuvent nous
toucher directement via un des éléments
qui contribuent potentiellement
peut-être ça aussi mais si les médias
sociaux j'ai comme pile à la
segmentation électorale où ce que les
gens et les partis politiques commencées
cible est de plus en plus certains
certains électeurs et donc des fois ça
faisait que tous les jeunes que ses
récents comme phénomène ce don n'est pas
exposé chacun aux mêmes informations
concrètes
et ciblées plus on reçoit des pubs
fournit de l'information
voisin qui est peut-être ciblé d'un
autre manière mais obtient différemment
évidemment ça construit ce espèce de
côté lorsque ben voyons donc comment
sais tu comprends pas pourquoi il était
comme si on était tous est exposé aux
mêmes informations
c'est aussi ça contribue un peu
peut-être cette polarisation j'élèverai
temps quelque chose qui contribue aussi
petit que je redis je pense que je me
trompe mais c'est aussi quand on regarde
les plateformes on se rend compte aussi
que des fois certains partis sur
certains d'hors-jeu s'est sensiblement
les mêmes propositions le tir il ya
vraiment beaucoup de trucs qui se
rejoignent trim et on met donc avec
celle d'ap et qu on prenne enfin en
commun parti libéral que la cac qui ont
plein en faire encore un rapport sur des
questions plus identitaire folle la
ferme en commun mais quand tu écoutes le
débo atv aux îles tille
ils débattent comme si l'hôte était la
pire chose de l'univers le tpiy vice
versa j'ai l'impression que si la
manière dont la politique est faite
puis comme l'impression qu'ils ont
vraiment choix de rentrer dans le jeu
d'être vraiment dur au viread avec
l'hôte et puis de
sart amplifie en finalement l'espèce de
différence qu'on pense qu'ils ont mais
finalement qui est qui m'aiment pas si
grande que c'est sûr qu'il ya des
consensus et rock dont on parle c'est
comme ça qu'il faut le voir discuter on
peut dire que c'est une démocratie on
dans une élection ce format et des choix
importants ce genre ne devraient jamais
ce que je vois un peu plus d'un an y
deux sociologues aussi une élection
quand même fascinant comme s'intéresse à
l'être humain je les vends une
compétition où est ce que tout le monde
est invité l'âge adulte liste wise
toutes invitées à contribuer d'une
certaine manière que je dis comme c'est
une joute de façon juste un jeu d'échecs
dans une façon jo patinec la magie de
ces cartes à puce ils savent ces gens là
je les scanne inspection tous amis tout
ça mais je dis et des gens de différents
partis qui vont mal une chanson me
l'offre de l'assemblée nationale s'est
vu que d'après celles ajoutées et c'est
une claque on le voit comme ça nous on
comprend mieux le fait que je veux après
des fois c'est bon de montrer garder
longtemps consensus faut soutenir sommes
à la fin son l'os c'est leur job c'est
une manière d'aller chercher puis on a
décidé de vivre dans un système comme ça
qu'on la démocratie ou est-ce que l'idée
je crois c'est de dire mais regardez le
sont aux mains des gens qui peuvent
choquer mais qui argumentent entrevue
que ça reste dans le respect menacé de
jute là dans quelque chose qui peut
peut-être semblait peut-être désagréable
à regarder mais il ya de l'information
puis il ya plus de responsabilité aussi
donc les gens peuvent dire quelque chose
mais tout à coup tu es lo que hay non
non non non qu'est ce que tu dis que
c'est comme un espèce d'équilibré aussi
cas qu'on la regarde de cet angle là
mais des fois on est peut-être moins
pessimiste quand on regarde un débat des
schistes et puis il ya mes amis qui
m'ont écrit après après le face à face
c'était justement pinzi comme c'est fou
parce qu' on dirait que ces cinq
personnes qui s'engueulent mais au final
les cinq personnes veulent selon leurs
provisions ce qui est le mieux pour le
québec et puis le fait que le résultat
aurait comme le même mais le chemin pour
y arriver c'est ce qu'ils disent faire
puis tout le monde s'engueule sur le
chemin pour y arriver alors que tout le
monde est l'objectif principal du club
du selon leur propre valeur le
mieux-être des québec quand même c'est
quand même fascinant quand je vois même
au site ça reste tout démonise pas les
gens à adopter oui absolument et
apprécié pour définir le bien-être du
québec c'est lorsqu'il ya quand même des
différences de valeurs quand même
fondamental
après ça il ya comme des questions je
prédis que son empire et qu'est ce qui
est le mieux pour moi est ce qu'on peut
s'entendre sur les principes
ils ont dit que l'on veut que le québec
soit plus riches
peut-être c'est une question de valeurs
soit mieux que les gens soient soient
bien mais là où je pense qu'on peut
avoir un consensus mais après ça il ya
comme des questions parce que des fois
les gens veulent le même objectif que si
c'est vrai que différents woippy il ya
un débat au pied des débats qui est la
science a pas encore tranché t leur rôle
de l'état ce que le rôle de l'état aille
d'une nuit est ce que est ce qu'on peut
le laisser faire économiquement ce que
c'est mieux pour l'économie ou est ce
qu'elle est ou est-ce que l'état doit
intervenir davantage même quand on a le
même objectif
des fois on ne sait pas c'est même deux
économistes forme égale
capacités intellectuelles égale dirait
deux choses complètement différentes
mais moi c'est ce qui me fascine parce
qu'ils me donnent le vertige pour que
j'ai tout le temps comme à mes étudiants
ce cadre on est chercheur projet
longtemps mais aussi gérer les ego aussi
parce que chaque chercheur au fond de
lui-même c'est exclure parce que comment
tu veux pas avoir le vertige devant
l'édifice de la connaissance je mange et
je vais signer parce que j'ai une
question de recherche j'ai une question
je me pose une question en rond dans la
littérature académique lieu des débats
et finit avec des gens qui ont fait
toute leur vie
c'est comme dans le principe de base est
que je regarde les cinq partis lorsque
j'ai pris des notes pendant les cinq
personnes devant moi c'est la
francisation ouais c'est important pour
les simples c'est sympa pour les cinq
méthyle le rôle de l'état sur la
francisation ces lettres sont moins
d'accord il ya des gens qui se mêle au
débat faut que l'état intervienne qu'on
force les gens à se préciser ce dont ils
feront pas aux personnes ne sont ni
vraiment gentil puis on quand mais je
veux savoir s'il ya une vision plus
libertaire d'entamer regardez le dans le
fond on a déjà donné les les bons
ingrédients
tout va se faire ça se passe autant que
moi c'est ce qui me fascine dont on
associe souvent la droite économique un
espèce de laisser faire c'est pas drôle
de l'état ont tenu le rôle de l'état
plus qu'un nouveau jury seule l'économie
fondée là dessus de la main invisible
jeter resterait donc son diminue le
l'intervention de l'état font qu'on
laisse les gens faire leurs propres
choix de mer décentralisé mais il ya
quelque chose qui va fort bien
fonctionné mais cette même réflexion
l'exécution d'un niveau social ce cas
qu'on parle autant de suffrages de la
francisation même si les valeurs
libérales on disait regardez peut-être
qu'on n'a pas besoin d'intervenir en
font les gens peut-être différents types
de valeurs mais dans le fond si on leur
donne des mêmes opportunités économiques
que l'état n'intervient pas mais ils
vont converger vers nos valeurs c'est
normalement puis si vous me demandez à -
c'est quoi le qui a raison je sais pas
moi c'est vraiment pas se présenter la
recherche sincère est importante des
difficultés en fait c'est sa voix qui
qu'est-ce-qui calculable empiriquement
puis qu'on peut trouver
vivement une réponse qu'est ce qui est
de l'or des valeurs puis que finalement
ça dépend
de l'opinion piqué pas nécessairement
une meilleure réponse alors suivre la
coupe des semaines jean martin aussant
s'est pas parlé d'économie tpiy
évidemment qu'ils exposeront qui est
l'ex politicien ou que ou qui étaient
les passionnés de politique ressort puis
qui compare les politiques seppi je m'en
ont parlé
d'une norme commune aux immigrants
campeurs telle qu'on peut accueillir par
année y en a qui disent 35000 de 50000
2010 88 et jean-martin t-il lui qui
quitte en gueule ultre cartésien tribun
calculons le tir calculons le faisons
ceux ci comme puis il comme sa surprise
après dangereux bâti faisons le fait-on
de calcul pile demandons la science
qu'on va arriver qu'une réponse qui
faisons ce poste c'est comme si tu es
sur plein d'aspects ça paraît logique
mais en même temps c'est 6 mars
la considération justement dit combien
d'immigrés qu'on peut accueillir
peut-être qu'on peut le calculer par
rapport à un aspect mais il ya tellement
d'aspects était justement que l'on parle
d'emploi peut-être qu'on peut calculer
mais qu'on parle de l'engloutir gauche
yves qui qu'on parle de cible quand par
dessus tout c'est idéologique le lequel
a priori ce thème c'était possible à
moins à moins qu'ils nous valoir comme
dans l'équation
général
mais dimension sociale c'est souvent le
cas il faut prendre des choix comme ceux
ci étaient sur quoi combattre nos choix
puis en effet des problèmes de données
c'est un problème de direction des
rançons pouvez répéter l'expérience
constamment soit pas une simulation et
quelques jours la bonne décision et 76
ans ont toujours un problème parce que
justement dimensionnés il faut
déterminer les principes de base qu'on
vise à compléter ce sens un truc que je
faisais comme donc déjà présumer des
données le plus riche possible de
personnes pour résumer c'est cessé de
maintenir le français puis on n'est pas
nécessairement
andrade alors c'est il faut déterminer
bon c'est quoi les principes principal
c'est quoi la meilleure façon d'y
arriver
oui il ya trop de paramètres oui quand
on peut regarder mais qu est ce qu on a
quand même comme donné on peut regarder
qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans le monde
peut-être une différence d'époque que
maintenant qu'est ce qu'on voit
maintenant ce même jour qu'il ya dix ans
aussi peut-être que le contexte
particulier du québec ne peut pas être
comparée à d'autres que tout ça fait
partie des paramètres mais le pire qu'on
me fasse assez découragés pour garder un
peu pour vite donc on se rabat ckoi
l'alternative donc j'y
mets soccer décès au coeur d'essayer de
pouvoir premièrement déterminer les
principes de pouvoir mesurer nos
concepts d'après c'est de pouvoir faire
des liens en ce qui concerne le plus
prendre les meilleures décisions
possibles puisque c'est sur quoi se
fonde justement sur l'induction fondée
sur des valeurs rapide comme ça moi je
pense que si où je pense que ce mais le
plus important c'est qu'on peut
s'étudier le sait losc se dit que
monsieur à saintes ça mais je suis
d'accord avec lui mais content qu'on
fasse le mieux qu'on peut me puis dans
les paramètres pour abc scientifique ya
déjà que pour le mesurer différemment il
ya des gens que l'on comparé deux femmes
et des jockeys mais ça c'est ce la
science que tout le monde qu'il ya un
débat scientifique
puis cap et recèlent ces gens là dans le
débat mais on veut nécessairement en
apprendre davantage qu'à la fin on
n'arrivera pas à trouver le club
d'avesnes chine andrew hall de la bonne
réponse mais au moins on va éclairer ont
éclairé le développement prend des
décisions en fonction paul ii donne une
valeur de déduction mais plutôt fondées
sur des données probantes est-ce que ce
l'on doit on le fait à 6 ans politique
au québec non mais moi je pense que on a
toujours essayé de le faire si je pense
qu'on a toujours toujours essayé de le
faire sauf que en ce moment où vient
époque vraiment particulière ce qu'il ya
vraiment une pluie de données autour de
nous le sert et de saint-orens
je pense que on a des possibilités de
tester des trucs comme jamais auparavant
c'est autant en tout les outils connus
de recherche publique de nikon donc on a
la capacité plus qu'avant puis non je
pense pas qu'en ce moment on appris
l'ensemble de toutes les opportunités
qui s'offraient à nous pour pouvoir
prendre ses décisions la fronde est là
dessus on le voit on
regarde les stratégies électorales ils
sont beaucoup adapté durant les deux
années de travail avec les mandarins qui
est elle au pied son édition petit avec
un débit des débits des stratèges qui
avait comme une personne en fuite alors
que les plus en plus partis politiques
on s'appuie de plus en plus sur des
données ce qu'on va avoir ton le vieux
qu'obama mon avance j'étais comme un
kindle
le tony blair
sion ont commencé avant une vision très
très très marketing sur les données
comment est ce qu'on peut apprendre sur
les données va
faire de l'analyse des sciences sociales
c'est de pouvoir cibler une stratégie
sur le terrain par rapport aux
circonscriptions ça c'est de moins en
moins les six institutions du conte dans
son chalet qui réfléchit à sa stratégie
électorale de plus en plus ancré sur les
données parce que parce qu'il ya plus de
données mais en même temps l'univers
numérique a convié sa certitude que l'on
poussé aussi dessus puis ont de moins en
moins choix de le faire que maintenant
mais on peut le faire aussi qu'il ya des
gens qui le font le jeu mais pour les
politiques publiques madame erreurs
systématiques de pouvoir développer puis
beaucoup d'initiatives ce qui existe
comme données québec parce que j'ai
vraiment un effort pouvoir centralisé
pts à nettoyer ces données la dîme est
accessible pour que les gens puissent
les analyser je prescris même si
formellement ouvert des données ouvertes
ou est-ce que vous et moi on pourrait en
question puis ces enjeux le fait comme
netflix permettons savoir exactement ce
que j'ai cliqué puis que lorsque j'ai et
puis qu'est-ce que pour me présenter
exactement les films plaisir y qui
m'intéressent impasse politique pourrait
enfin peu la même stratégie finalement à
un connaissant assez donné sachant qu
est ce que la population du québec veut
bien commun les directions
c'est exact c'est ce que j'allais dire
parce qu'on dirait que ces données ne
sont pas vraiment choisi de façon
vraiment électoralistes on dirait que la
journée où est ce que la campagne
électorale débutée tout le monde sortait
s'astique de de réductions d'impôts ou
de chèque non le conte envoyé aux gens
on dirait que ça ce n'est vraiment pas
quelque chose qui était étudié comme
étant
façon de régler le problème de
l'inflation mais ton mais qui était un
mot vraiment
électoraliste où tu en es juste à penser
au troisième bien où est ce qu'il ya
de façon claire pas d'étude de la
défaite pas de donner des études entre
que
vous pouvez pas mettez en direct on
dirait que ces données leur qui sont
prises sont pas prises pour que main qui
s'y colla meilleure solution mais c'est
quoi le double la chose qui me laisse le
plus de chances d'une part et les hommes
dont s'est pour une fois on fait la
distinction c'est moi que c'est ma faute
j'ai fait les chinois ont parlé de
politique publique on n'a pas tourné
vers l'élection c'est des trucs
différents comme ça mais en même temps
aussi par rapport aux études par rapport
très optimiste sur la capacité de
pouvoir faire mieux que dallas d'aller
chercher des données de mettre vraiment
les sciences sociales puis des au coeur
des décisions politiquement même temps à
la fin va toujours rester un moment où
ce que les politiques vont prendre une
décision est-ce qu'on n'aurait jamais la
science doit jamais arriver qu'un truc
là-bas voilà votre jour dépendent du
principe de base qui est fondée sur des
valeurs qui dépend de notre projet de
société
ça aussi mais ça fait partie aussi
notice thème la responsabilité la
politique la leadership c'est les gens
qui comprend des décisions en fonction
de valeurs perd la face on attend tout
le temps après tout d'avoir vraiment une
certitude mais il ya plein de surprendre
leur pop pourra pas prendre un par
contre c'est important que ce qui nous
attend on parlait justement
d'immigration que je pense que ces
enjeux le cac au risque a sévi une
manière de politique publique mais
qu'elle peut décemment tabou partir
qu'on en parle on en discute puis se
sont placés ans ou 6 1 on a déjà parlé
le mot
ce que ça prendrait essentiellement
c'est un dr manhattan comme dans
watchmen qui est comme un dictateur
ultime que le tout la cie en cours à
ses
fantasmes justement mai mais je pense
que justement entendons parler des
études électorale diront c'est
exactement comme un non parce que dans
le fond toujours de las il ya toujours
un très probable islandais toujours des
modèles
par rapport à ça puis le code avait une
chine n'existe pas on pourrait pas de
trouver qu'il va toujours rester comme
un paramètre la discussion si votre
machine j'ai pensé aussi je faisais
comme la machine mais la machine va
falloir quand même leur donner de dire
c'est quoi qu'on optimise qu'est-ce
qu'on optimise en ce moment c'est quoi
le but l'objectif sur la survie de
l'humanité ceux de venise elle
s'enrichit il va quand même avoir cette
question là bas c'est d'aller coloniser
d'autres planètes généralement la faim
et la machine c'est toucher les 10
questions philosophiques
exactement après ça oui mais après c'est
pour atteindre du point d' aller du
point a au point b même ce sont nos
valeurs et des politiques nos visions
d'humanité qui nous visions de où s
conserve quentin comme société
m'apprécier moi je crois quand même que
que des meilleures façons d'arriver avec
plusieurs façons aussi c'est lorsque je
pense pas qu'on peut s'en sortir comme
ça ouais je n'écris pas de bailout non
c'est saint sauveur je pense que c'est
toujours important de discuter
parseval on n'a pas tellement le mot
projet de société que ça ne dit plus
rien ou presque mais c'est vrai si on a
la balle il faut qu'on se sont cons
qu'on s'entend sur c'est quoi notre
projet de société c'est ce qu'ont être
qu'on développe une culture commune où
est ce que chacun et chacun pour soi
mais qu'on donne des bonnes mais des
bonnes conditions matérielles est ce que
je pense population peut vraiment
répondre à cette question
avant qu'on rentre dans
le survol des plateformes des partis
j'ai une question pour le statisticien
puis le passionné de sondage qui était
moi mettons
sur la boussole électorale j'arrive
vraiment entre tes québec solidaire le
pq la kakul parti libéral j'arrive en
plein centre de soute
pis ce qui fait que tu aies j'ai des
affinités avec tous ses partenaires puis
toutes les lignes éditoriales de ces
partis le
peux tu m'expliquer où selon toi
d'où vient l'appui
majoritaire
écrasant
à la cac parce que maintenant moi je
suis pas plus je peux concevoir placca
qui va et telus et je peux concevoir
qu'ils gagneraient la majorité des qui
gangrène le plus de sièges mais ton je
peux concevoir sur le selon leur
politique puis le fait qu' il me
rejoigne le temps que d'autres parties
le ton mais
objectivement
support rené leveret khl avec un avec du
charisme il ya un projet de société
c'est pas un affaire complètement
rassembleur cpoté je peux concevoir
qu'ils vont gagner puis même que moi
peut-être mon vote est pas encore
déclarée puis ça se pourrait que je vote
pour la cac à la fin de l'histoire mais
peux tu expliquer pourquoi selon toi
pourquoi est-ce que c'est aussi écrasant
com com avance avance en ce moment les
sondages
pour une très bonne question je devais
commencer vraiment qu'elle soit 1000
pièces jeu c'est vraiment ça ça reste à
étudier jeudi manger c'est sûr je
regarde les sondages c'est ce qui
m'intéresse je pense que là la cac et
très très très bon en communication mais
aussi en marketing dansante le marketing
politique des fois qu'on parle de
marketing politique on le définit
souvent en mal d'enfant de marketing ont
longtemps qu'elle se bat comme la
propagande alors que ces cons de la
manipulation mais c'est presque le grand
que c'est presque le contraire parce que
dans le fond le marketing le marketing
provient de quelque chose qui s'est
passé dans le monde commercial
ou est-ce que l'idée c'était de dire
regardez moi je m'explique ce puits dont
je suis les spéciales qui est à côté le
centre mais mes compétiteurs puis donc
j'en fais plus de publicité puis je
remette des trucs pour que les gens
voient des images
casbah subliminal pour convaincre les
gens d'acheter mais mikko et flex à moi
c'est le marketing
sinon c'est peut-être pas la meilleure
façon d'utiliser nos ressources
peut-être que la meilleure façon c'est
de faire intervenir la recherche de
marchés donc moi qui tu ris âge avant la
production se produit donc essayons
d'aller voir les gens qu est ce qui m a
vingt pilotes of construisons donc en
flex du cerveau se vendent bien mieux
après parce que les gens sont pas
stupides que les gens ont des
préférences donc son vol vers les gens
on les écoute on
développe le produit puis non complexes
d'entente nul donc c'était aller après
la rencontre la propagande parce qu'on
pensait qu'on était capable de laver le
cerveau d'une société libre devant népal
en maintenant thème l'école flakes alors
que jamais
la période mais c'est simple mais vu des
bribes là dans la banque commerciale
parce que comme coca cola ge pas si vous
avez déjà entendu parler de toute
l'expérience de coke 2 mai à la veille
qu'à composer goûter du coca cola il se
pète si les gens préfèrent et pepsi coca
cola capoter qui ont changé la formule
du coca cola et après cette course 2 un
étudiant échec de liste rose banking que
vivent là dessus ce qui est intéressant
mais ça reste un coquard du marketing
c'est ludique la recherche de marché
arrive avant la production ppi nom
marketing politique pour avoir une
valeur définitionnelle faut que ça fasse
un clin d'oeil à seul ballon donc l'idée
c'est de dire mais regardez avant de
construire une plateforme électorale de
demain les gens comprennent pas on va ce
sera plus de pub on veut juste voir plus
de peur on va les chercher du charisme
on va le chercher des pions avant de la
pub tout mais politique c'est plus
compliqué parce que là bas aussi squid
fondée sur des principes et ces rachats
mais non mais peut-être qu'on peut
ajuster notre produit on peut ajuster
notre chef on peut ajuster notre
plateforme qui est la majorité des
électeurs veulent et créons cette
plateforme exactement pitié le conseil
de triangulation bill clinton était très
fort
sur les blogs comme sur les thématiques
gauche droite un peu l'équivalent aux
états unis puis lui ai dit non regarde
moi je peux
positionné oui parti démocrate gauche
même tâche peut être top en prime en
même temps je peux peut-être m'attaquer
aussi pour les taxes et les impôts s'il
y avait comme un slogan sur la campagne
de bill clinton qui est très très très
connu sa pelle edberg economy stupid il
était écrit sur le tableau train que les
gens rentraient dans le bunker
électorale pour garder sa focus sur
l'économique ce qu'ils vont nous
attaquer là dessus de la même chose
était reprise après à meymac des
certains stratèges commun par tony blair
ses calculs le leader travailliste
est toujours attaquer sous la même chose
de faire des élections après une après
l'autre finalement mais ils se sont
repositionnés encore dove crème tough on
crime des trucs comme ce petit et sont
appelées même le new labour parti
conservateur très très fort probable de
segmentation électorale aussi au canada
stephen harper très très fort je fais de
mon mémoire de maîtrise là dessus que
j'ai même continué à presser heures
c'est fascinant leur positionnement du
parti concertant 2004-2006 tfs n'est pas
parti qui provenait du reform party
soyez prêt au début de présenter même
pour des candidats au québec sont
repoussés en 2004 2006 à faire un
fédéralisme d'ouverture à se
repositionner à reconnaître la nation
québécoise non pas juste l'action du
québec mais elle se repositionner sur la
santé était pour la santé a privé les
dinos non on va même diminué non
seulement
renforcer le système public ils sont
repoussés sur plein d'enjeux comme ça
pourquoi ce qu'avaient certains segments
c'est un segment qui était fondée ou
vous avez parlé de faire un beau projet
de taiji c'est exactement ça l'idée et
des segments qui te fondée sûr il y
avait comme le segment ciseaux et qui
buvaient ses cafés lattés au starbucks
fait de duke a été rachetée racheter le
président et où elle allait coup de quoi
qui seront trop peu on dépassera pas un
sou publ parce qu'on ne leur ai jamais
on essaierait de convaincre xue
puis au québec c'est où c'est tout ça à
québec dans la ville de québec quant aux
fans notre note notre notre notre merci
conférence
comment annoncer notre fédéralisme
d'ouverture à le faire à québec qu'à
montréal aussi le plateau on va le faire
à québec au sommet vous voyez c'est un
aspect marketing d'aso la caq très forte
j'étais comme qui va devoir aller
chercher des segments de faire une
segmentation
peut-être gardé une certaine clientèle
qui aime si certains cadavres qui aiment
se doit d'aller prendre la voie du
milieu comme ça on le voit en santé on
le voit dans plein plein plein plein
plein plein d'enjeu mais cette
information là qu'est ce qui t'intéresse
ans était seul à base de tai-chi de dire
regardez là ça c'est des données que les
parties ont que les compagnies ont écrit
des modèles comme ça on nous met comme
dans des préjugés des inférences mais
c'est ce que les gens font ce que
statisticien font que dans le fond de ta
gauche et vous emmène c'est le contrat
la boussole électorale on dit mais
l'ombre basse et de prêter votre vote
sans poser une seule question se repose
sur les enjeux politiques c'est comme ça
s'est développé ces textes est là parce
que je tenais qu'elle les gestes des
achats directs orale vous avez mal pris
mon vote journée peut-être que j'ai même
pas besoin de vous poser cette question
sous les enjeux de cette façon là donc à
la baguette chaude protection ou est ce
que c'est votre café été rachetée
restera à la fin fait leur dissimulation
pouvoir et qu'elle variable et france
voir votre petit comprendre dans quel
comment est ce que vous avez été
socialisés dans une façon que c'est
l'information les parties longues c'est
que puis les l'appareillage pour aider
de communication publique beaucoup
évolué durant deux années donc avant on
faisait des macros campagne vous
comprenez qu'on prenne des positions sur
les trucs qu'on appelait des enjeux de
valence que personne est en désaccord
dont on vous promet une bonne économie
au premier de leur propre aux premiers
pas de crime dans la rue ce qui est fait
c'est même là absente man de dieppe on
demande au canada parce que les partis
c'est tellement hétérogènes canada que
les parties prennent un vote nous aussi
on fait il y avait le parti libéral puis
avait le parti progressiste conservateur
mais mais au québec comme ça en ce
moment mais au canada partout dans le
monde ce qu'on est capable maintenant de
faire le prépare ta question là segment
de la segmentation électorale c'est ici
on est capable de viser des certains
segments donc qu'est ce que vous voyez
comme information que tu me campagne
c'est peut-être pas la même que d'autres
personnes qu'est-ce qu'ils ont inventé
ça selon donc c'est pour ça qu'il ya
comme un aura de mystère autour de ce
débat et voilà pourquoi les pires des
parties montent ou descendent c'est oui
les face à face débat des chefs à ce que
toute la société peut le voir le regard
des pouvoirs l'effet de ce mets tout là
qu'est ce que j'appelle la micro
campagne les petits pubs sur des enjeux
vraiment précis dans cette région à la
radio on les voit pas donc pourrait voir
la question faudrait avoir plus de
données puis testé sur puis voix rauque
et qu'est ce qui fonctionne et qu'est-ce
que peut fonctionner puis elle mais je
pense que la caq ou s'ils se positionne
beaucoup entre plusieurs parties ont dix
d'une coalition noire québec donc c'est
vraiment une coalition donc cela sur
l'enjeu du tout sûrs en dit long de la
gauche droite
mettons dire que c'est là vécu donc
c'est de droite c'est un élément de
regarde le sol et cpe comme sur
l'éducation date les gens se rappellent
peut qu'être là qu'a été lancée mais sur
l'éducation est très très très de gauche
la gauche droite la liste souverainiste
russie dispose d un peu entre les deux
sont nationalistes donc si ça va
chercher comme peut-être ici un
consensus par rapport à ces essais
d'aller chercher deux temps le consensus
puis à leur gauche jacques us à leur
droite mais maintenant le pc
je pense que
la mecque des autres partis politiques
ou si les problèmes aussi que peut-être
que le parti libéral du québec a eu
depuis l'époque charest qui tournent
vers des camps anglade où est ce qu'ils
se positionnent sur le gauche droite
commencent à émerger mais tout cela plus
bien ici peut-être on parle même pas de
l'effet de la pandémie
nation
c'est mon opinion mais j'ai vraiment
l'impression c'est un parti si justement
qui connaît très bien les donner aux
québécois sont tannés d'entendre parler
des référendums on a perdu le tpiy les
québécois veulent si on parle sur nana
qui justement en ayant toutes ces
données le en s'ajustant baissé comme on
vous présente ce que vous voulez mais
j'ai besoin c'est ça le succès de cet
artiste cotiser sur la segmentation les
dd du lectorat le
tantôt dans l'oeuf est le dada gâchis
puis ont gelé fait aussi piqué les deux
maisons même si on est vraiment au
d'ensemble de quatre parties on sort
québec solidaire à côté selon nos modes
de vite et la dame dans touche pas
devant bureau puis 10
mais ce qu'on attend c'est est ce que
c'est en notre choix
d'avoir
déterminisme ce temps notre choix parce
qu'au final si c'est un peu
une vision de
moi si je me fie à mon fils d'instagram
twitter je vois jusqu'à l'extérieur
c'est tout le jeu le pressing les
réseaux sociaux sympathie qu'il est
maintenant qu'il ya pas d'autres parties
du monde est présent
puis ça en dit long sur un complément le
fait qu'on ait ciblé potentiellement et
piquant qu'au bout du chemin ce nouveau
média sociaux ça y est ce aussi comme
comme ça c'est pas les partis politiques
pour eux n'ont pu rentrer le fait que
des gens qui ne m'avaient pas que sinon
même et il ya des structures
institutionnelles comprise comme des
structures logiciel c'est comme facebook
mais vous choisi vous vous choisissez
vos amis
vous auto sélectionné à cette
information-là puis comme des effets
comme sur deux chambres d'écho ou est-ce
que les legends renforcent leurs idées
puis se parle de moins en moins ça
revient au problème de polarisation
juste à main posé comme deux pôles en ce
sens on a de la misère à comprendre
l'autre zone de façon sexy quand on
comprend qu'on est socialisé d'une
certaine façon que j'étais comme vu que
je suis né en telle année j'ai grandi
dans les endroits je prends un immigré
intérêt je te restera sur price the
prize que je pensais mais afin et le
problème c'est qu'on pense à cesser la
vérité c'est celui qu'on comprend plus
l'autre du tout du tout on a un
esthétisme commun on est l'ombre au café
et son beau gars québécois un café saint
henri à montréal
avec le tabac en bois tantôt schuster ou
névés sur rachel table en bois avec les
gens avec les tatouages acclamait
musique métal et quoi choix brooklyn
joue à tokyo se joue à signer mais on
retrouve ce même s'ils disent non comme
par hasard il pense quand même pas tout
le monde a bien fait votre parlement un
peu pour la
mais ce que le bon goût existe
réellement ou est-ce que les gens tu
t'en vas ailleurs que je t'avais dans
des festivals justement des camionneurs
récemment que les
chaînes avec des avec des bébés
casquette avec avec dezègue dessus tout
je sais que certains que mes amis qui
vont danser qui a fait le tour annoncé
esthétiquement propre les ans onta
williams aux pauvres sais pas quel
mauvais goût jusqu'à qui partagent notre
dimension symbolique puis à ceci les
trucs c'est certain que ça a un lien
avec la politique c'est vrai que ça a un
lien que la politique pour comprendre
l'autre comment qu'on fait on peut
s'intéresser
aux sur youtube on a contacté de trois
affaires peut maintenant dire quels
gestes mais c'est un peu la même idée
aussi cessé de s'intéresser à l'autre
comment qu'on fait pour s'intéresser à
l'autre il faut faire l'effort faut
faire l'effort jeux disponibles commencé
à suivre des amis un peu rennes 2-1 à
d'autres bulles mais moi ça m'intéresse
le constat comme politologue ce serait
le sujet mais j'aime beaucoup beaucoup
ceux ci pour être d'attaqué j sais c'est
exactement cette idée l'idée c'est de
dire regardez la fête les attaques de
chiper à la fin allez dans la simulation
puis changer une de vos variable c'est
toute chose des tensions en toutes
choses égales et égales par ailleurs
mais c'est toute chose étant égale à
vous donc ph tu le fais je mets comme
une femme mais comme un immigré comme
pilote tout à coup tu vois les fixes à
la sur le vote toutefois peut-être
réalisé qu'il m'a peut-être qu'il ya des
trucs ça m'intéresserait à comprendre
l'autre je prédis que dans d'autres
circonstances que ce pôle est fait de
boire son café ou au saint henri versus
le thé morton qui fait que tout à coup
tout devient conservateur mais c'est
peut-être un marqueur un marqueur pour
moi pour comprendre dans quel univers où
unités sociologie que ce que vous êtes
la même façon qu'on sait que les femmes
les hommes voient pas de la même façon
mais spontanément l'estrogène qui est
qui faisait que les femmes votent
différemment puis comme les
afro-américains va différemment des
blancs états unis mais se pressent la
pigmentation de la peau cissé qui c'est
un groupe ii c'est un groupe qu une
socialisation qu'une histoire commune
qui partage de symboles comme un puits
mais de la même façon les gens qui ont
des tatouages qui savait de cette façon
qu'ils coûtent tel type de musique mais
le fait qu'on essaie d'être déterminé
c'est quoi ces nouvelles je pressais
frontières de cette unité sociologique
là puis d'essayer de comprendre leur
logique interne puis nous on le comprend
avec des mots créatis d'information la
démocratisation des modèles complexes
mais les compagnies puis les partis
politiques sont aussi ces informations
il faut poser la question comme data que
je vois si ça fonctionne ça fonctionne
pas mais vous c'est aussi intéressant
que ça fonctionne pas mais vincent
fonctionne pas sa personne parce que
justement il ya pas de code davinci
justement il ya pas de détermination là
dedans mais ces modèles seront hyper
utilisé dans le monde commercial dans
nos politiques n'ont donc quand vous
n'êtes pas bien pris 10 mais ça veut
dire que des limites à ces modèles là
mais ça veut dire quand même que quand
que des modèles kaka des limites à ces
modèles locaux koné pop sont pas
démocratiques et tourner la scène mais
vous savez quand même ce type de
publicité la
presse que le des commandes et on s'en
échappe aux leçons se mettre la tête
dans sa existe pas moi qui ai inventé la
gare de l'agha chill on utilise des
agressions très très très utilisé là
ouais mais tu voi j'étais surpris à quel
point tu attaques et étaient plus
convaincu de mon vote que moi même c'est
dans ce sens qu'il est clair pour qu'il
se débattait pu booster com
mais
lorsqu'on essaie d'aller les plateformes
fois discuté de dit il faut faire
attention la scène pour déterminer ce
nous a fait réfléchir à votre vote à
l'élan simulation pour voir les les
variables qui explique ce soit le vote m
software ag vite la cgt comme un pied
des variables comme ça tu peux explorer
c'est quoi les aspects et puis c'est
vrai qu'à des gens qui sont
difficilement modélisable et j'ai vu des
jeunes à risque dans mais ça fonctionne
pas pour moi mais c'est déjà le cas
quand son hyper sophistiqué qui on pense
à l'appel une fraction de la population
c'est le plus difficile à modéliser les
plus difficile à modéliser c'est normal
que ça fonctionne moins bien pour ces
gens là tout pour la madame tout le
monde le sait ce sont des trucs à faire
réfléchir mais justement comment est-ce
qu'on peut casser su convaincre on peut
réfléchir à ça mais c'est ça la
politique actuelle la politique moderne
ça se passe avec des derniers mais
risque ça nous aurait on parlait de
données probantes plutôt de cépie j'ai
l'impression que c'est un peu
l'utilisation et verse des données dans
ce sens que le sait c'est admet donc
l'opinion publique ce terrain en jeu x
et a dit que les données probantes les
études nous disent il faut faire b b le
le parti politique se retrouve quand
même dans un genre de problème entre
parce qu'il sait qu'il faut qu'ils
fassent b mais si qu'il vous faut se
faire élire il faut qu'ils disent
qu'est-ce qu'on fait
des bonnes pratiques devient très très
important c'est lorsqu'elle comme
justement tél la raison je sais qu'il ya
déjà en tournée mme polaschik on aime
pas que des bottes titre mais à la fin
si quelqu'un dit vraiment quelque chose
d'aberrant mais ce fait il se peut que
je ne parle pas d'un parti en
particulier mais un certain qu'ils font
qui promettent des trucs qui sont
vanessa fondées sur des données
probantes puis on en parle beaucoup dans
mes dix ans - pourquoi tant qu après un
terrible c'est ça la démocratie c'est
normal que ça se passe comme ça donc
chacun des partis il y un peu que ça
rejoint plus qu est-ce qu on parlait
tout à l'heure c'est chaque partie un
peu comme un raccourci d'une façon
quitter pour vous pouviez non plus hein
un des trucs un portable 4h parti
politique mais un tableau aussi la base
des bénévoles d'abord ces gens là sont
souvent beaucoup plus d eau logique que
les gens pressés d'aller chercher de
vote mais qu'il faut une certaine
cohérence dans tout ça des fois il ya
mieux qu'un système parfait ne voudrais
pas que mon code davinci mais de ce qui
est intéressant c'est quoi un système
dirigé par fait complètement cohérente
recettes qui veut toujours arriver comme
si vous maintenez une certaine cohérence
autour de moi un point que ce soit
valence est petit ça prend des décisions
les positions que les plus difficiles
que chaque partie ses positions le
faux qui maintiennent l'équilibré là
parce que les électeurs qui vont puis
vous savez quoi mais les autres partis
sont là pour essayer d'aller chercher
ses électeurs loin ception on a perdu
une des tactiques de la date du web
la politique de brèches d'essayer de
trouver c'est quoi la brèche percée dans
la coalition seul dans la coalition
black is nicolet c'était des gens là
peut-être sont pas d'accord avec la
partie c'est lorsque le microciblage la
vie vraiment fascinant bien intéressante
c'est vraiment et pour être efficace que
si j'avais une des co créatrice d'agesci
c'est catherine ouellet tic été créés
sans son doctorat je commence ou six ans
le sur lifetime puisque mon éditeur de
la maîtrise sa maîtrise sur le micro
ciblage des conservateurs sur l'enjeu
des des armes à feu pourquoi parce que
moins connus au québec mais une base
néodémocrate yvon la ccim des
néo-démocrates à l'urbain intelligent et
remettre sur mevlut une culture dans
l'ontario rural dans le combat
britanniques rural j'avais des positions
très très forte sur le registre des
armes à feu pour plaire à leur base
urbaine mais il ya plein de néo
démocrate qui était démocrate de
génération en génération mais qui qui
étaient des chasseurs mais ce qui
économiquement sont plus à gauche mais
sur le point de vue des hommes à fond
exactement donc qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait mais les conservateurs ont commencé
à viser ces électeurs là catherine est
fait des entrevues avec les stratèges de
conservateurs très très décidé comme ça
donc fait ce but pub dans l'ontario
justement qu'on ne peut pas nous voir la
télé des pubs à la radio de 110 ans
oubliez paul oublier penser quand les
les néo-démocrates qui vous
fait que penser
de pousser un enjeu pour que les gens
constatent dangereux le cac m'en aller
voter ouais ouais c'est percevoir le
voit vraiment cool eux se tait juste
l'exemple frappant dedans ou au
face-à-face tv aucun cas je postule à
regarder bonjour le maire l'écouté je
t'envoie tout donc je l'écouté je n'ai
jamais oublié le segment où est-ce que
où est ce que pierre saint paul par le
monde on est comme force gabriel dubois
a nommé le nom d'un livre c'est puis le
juste pour comme s'assurer que les
belles la gauche donc le kit une base
électorale faure de québec solidaire
soit comme ce qui est brusque et par
l'utilisation du moment n sur les sommes
placées comme cette espèce de change le
vraiment besoin
ouais ok
c'est comme si possible il exactement le
type est en plus probablement que pour
le pq qu'avec soldats ce peut être le
parti le plus proche où aller chercher
des votes maintenant l'outil fake
d'essayer d'aller dans les quartiers de
cheikh gueye dumont à m
bon c'est pas que c'était ce que les
magistrats soient sa housse wac espérait
peut-être je ne sais pas
les radicaux
que ce système ait ce genre notre cas
aussi servant le débat c'était un débat
on écoutait le débat puis comme je
disais je les écoutais genève est
intéressant skoda aux états unis est
tout en humanité ratures là dessus sur
les gens que liu zhongquing diverses
sections les gens qui est cavelli qu'il
avait écouté ça le regarde et avait
donné une excellent gagnant puisque la
ville regarder la télévision avait donné
john f.kennedy gagne j'en tiendrais pas
dire sur moi même en tant dans ma
voiture lui coûter 600 salles voix
qu'est ce qui se passe mais mes la phase
qui est différent maintenant
pas tant parce que l'enfant les gens
apprécient peu d'erreurs et on dit
soyons du sopi donner des entrevues aux
journaux de ça mais quand même
maintenant c'est un efficace qui peut
aller chercher une clip ne va pousser je
ne sais pas je n'ai pas regardé je vais
pas donner des détentions à aucun des
partis mais moi si ce temps que c'est
comme ça que j'ai vu ce cas car mon bus
quand éric duhaime parle en anglais
ouais carrément madame anglade ce
qu'il fait parce que je pense que si les
anglophones les coups de crosse à ce
moment un format d'image afin de mes
amis je demande le funk message à
l'écouté mais c'était un traduction
simultanée en français
mais non mais je me dis à patates quelle
idée je sais j'en aucune des notes et
mémé pataclope libéré plaide le clip il
a renvoyé après fait que tu aies chacun
il faut fois un certain respect pour un
certain courage parce que moi j'étais
stressée de venir ici en sachant que
d'avoir déjà qu'elle aime écouter à
savoir que chaque truc tout d'abord
derrière toi mais tu as face la danse il
ya des pièges partout c'est un spot il
faut le voir comme un jeu tous les we et
puis sans enfant mais enfin et surtout
celui ci la
jeunesse était souvent dans les mains à
des boxs j'ai regardé le parce que moi
aussi j'ai vraiment trouvé même si
évidemment il ya des boîtes cacophonique
comme dans tous les débats ça sera
impossible de faire des bosses sans
segment cacophonie que tout le monde
crie après moi aussi j'ai trouvé que
c'était quand même assez précis comme
des petits rats de comprendre ce que les
parties proposées
septembre sur hbo forme après mon jeu je
pense qu'au bout forment le face à face
justement ça réduit un peu rauque à
convaincre ford mais en même temps je
pense que devant une brochette de cinq
partis comme seul c'est très différent
du monde il ya des trucs qui est qui les
rassemble merci des rôles c'est le pcq
je pense que tu accueilles actuelle avec
des leaders tous excellents mais non
c'était vraiment un bon débat puis a pas
eu beaucoup de boue de plâtre peint non
mais oui par rapport aux il ya toutes
des équipes de réseaux sociaux et de
marketing charmant la télé t on parler d
agrippine tes mots sommet réseaux
sociaux où je veux juste qu'avec celle
d'arrêter mais le débat était même pas
fini qui avait déjà des clips des
extraits de ce segment avec une belle
infographie avec qui il y avait qui
demande c'est que pendant le truc c'est
comme qui se regonflent ont fait le
montage
non mais c'est intense campagne
électorale pour les gens qui sont
impliqués dont je tape un peu du côté
comme un acadien que je pourrais même
temps on a un lien sur l'absence à
crédit candidate à gauche et avec la
presse canadienne
c'est intense juste pour moi je peux
même pas m'imaginer ces quads et chef de
parti je
comprends pour redresser ses seins une
des intrigues que j'ai un dépistage
comme ces gens alors qu'ils couchent le
soir arrive à un méta % de regard et va
dormir c'était ta tête tout une clause
sur tes épaules c'est des gens qui
défendent la survie de leurs partis
d'autres personnes qui défendent le
gouvernement
de prendre le gouvernement je sais c'est
une grosse grosse job et c'est vraiment
incroyable
cela
dit je pense que les gens sont vraiment
influencé par qui est le chef de parti
qui préfère arrêter justement être temps
de débat qui qui qui qui y ont trouvé
qu'ils avaient plus de charisme et qui
ont trouvé qu était qu'il y avait plus
d'affinités avec les autres est-ce qu'on
accorde trop d'importance au chef du
parti ce que les gens votent trop pour
un chef passer pour un parti où ça va
mais parce que ça n'est pas parce que je
pense qu'on
une question empirer km2 de qu'est ce
que je vois pour résumer ma fondée sur
une certaine théorie c'est qu'on accorde
trop d'importance aux chats parce que je
pense qu'un billet énorme c'est souvent
on va aimer notre chef le cas quand
d'autres raisons ça serait intéressant
de le faire aller à toi mec avec des
expériences et ses galeries nadeau
dubois était le chef du pc cus éric
duhaime tel chef de québec solidaire
parce que c'est ce que les gens et les
soldats ski d'été seraient récusées
montant qu'il déteste aujourd'hui et
selon moi l'effet du chiffre des coûts
serait pas mal moins importante après
c'est ça l'important c'est certain
c'est la figure ce parti c'est sûr un
effet par apa rsa après c est ce qu on
met trop d'importations on parle de
personnalisation de la politique pas
part au chef toi c'est vraiment une
question justement normes at il dit mais
ce qui manquait c'était con con qu'on
veut embarquer mais moi si ça permet des
gens de pouvoir suivre mul déjà qu'ils
sont occupés qu'ils sont pas là dedans
qui ont pas attendu ça chaque jour des
débats par fait qu'un camp lui parle
quand elle elle parle mais je faisais ça
c'était le party puis donc j'écoute je
sais si c'est aux parties mais ça peut
être positif façon c'est un raccourci
comme un autre je parlais jack layton à
part moi je m'en souviens très bien
centre-ville et la typicité
tu es tu avais le goût de l'amélie
arrive là il était fort halak sidiki
tant par les animals pigeard le
lendemain tout le monde jack layton
ccu upa il paraît
bon exemple qui donne parce que le c'est
vrai que c'est alors qu'on allait lille
pourra parfois des données au niveau
ce niveau n'a vraiment granulaire
l'autre côté coeur de voir l'effet de
demont apache les l'équipe les
anglo-québécois ses déplacements par
jour ses droits les faits exacts
qu'est-ce qu'on avait observé ce que sur
l'attitude de jack layton c'est vraiment
une grosse monde en parle mais pas
nécessairement sur les intentions de
vote directement sa pris quelques temps
puis dans le reste du pays est aussi
limpide et monte aussi puis finalement
le premier sondage les faits ou ce qu'on
a vu le plus gros saut dans les
intentions de vote au québec c'était
petites épaules tout le monde en parle
c'était le premier sondage qui montre et
le npd en avant du bloc québécois ou est
ce qu'on les a vus cet effet là c'est
chez les anglo québécois on a vu un gros
gros saut parce que tu as là je vous
disais il ya plein de raisons pour voter
pour un parti pour votre préfère c'est
ce qu'on devrait voter pour le parti qui
représente le mieux qu est ce qu on
pense qu'on devrait voter pour le parti
qui t'ont trop car le mieux la partie
qu'on aime le moins cher mais là tout à
coup il
ya un autre choix puis peut-être selon
keolis et je te parle en tête des
anglo-québécois intérêts qui ont ce bel
bloc avec homs et leurs menaces première
cas qui ont vu que le step une menace
mais il se sentait plus libres d'aller
voter autre chose que parti libéral mais
vous voyez la dynamique ce qui est
intéressant mais médecins tout en mixant
une stratégie mais mais le mythe
d'oedipe jaquette ne passait plus le
lendemain eu la vague orange et
moi c'est juste effet grâce à ce que
j'avais pété
km et puis si on parle de stratégie nous
pouvons parler de marketing mais des
fois on oublie dans cette histoire de la
vague orange le parti npd avait quand
même pris des positions là à sherbrooke
sur des
dépositions quand même déposé la loi 100
sur des trucs et des veaux cgf des
pulsions y avait mille fleurs de lys sur
leur logo que tu y aller chercher les
segments québec il y avait une volonté
n'était ce pas je citais des fois j'ai
entendu dans ce temps le stand mais non
au sud à toronto que j'attendais des
mythes qui l' incroyable de dire à plat
dit que c'est le repositionnement du npd
sur le québec tuera protection si les
progrès des ddd juridiction provinciale
il ya même eu pas réfléchi prof le japon
des preuves dans le fond la can de jack
layton la piste peut-être la can de
lucien bouchard
matinée il y avait eu un
repositionnement est pas parce qu il
faudrait peut-être plus de données fois
plus d'étudiants et ce au moment des
débats académiques sud qu est-ce qu les
films c'est sa naissance mais avait
quand même un à un un effort conscient
du npd pour obtenir le québec mais elle
va tout le monde en parle avant même le
début de la campagne
on veut on voulait aussi faire un survol
des plateformes mais des parties sur
certains enjeux puis le tuer les gens
qui nous écoutent
l'idée c'est de simplifier
l'offre qui nous est offert dans le fond
puis je pense que la pesée d'intérêts
c'est vraiment un bon outil pour faire
ce mail vous êtes encore en train
d'écouter vous n'êtes pas encore rendus
sur le site de la boussole électorale
fait que je pense que c'est intéressant
de voir un thon les grandes lignes de
chaque partie sur quelques enjeux
le premier problème est que moi c'est
lui c'est lui le voit parler plus
personnellement c'est lui qui me touche
le plus c'est l'environnement on parle
l'élection de l'environnement pour
pendant toutes les parties du sort même
là je pense que tout le monde s'entend
pour vouloir sauver la planète
si tu assistes assez clair mais ya quand
même des niveaux à tout seul non c'est
ce que je veux dire que j'étais à ces
questions parce que justement cas qu'on
rentre dans dans la signification des
plateformes électorales a dit regardez
la gauche la droite on de position n'a
plus qu'à les voir électorale s'est
passé relativement facile de passe
différents participants et qu'elles ont
souverainiste lesquels sont fédéralistes
lesquels sont plus de gauclin qu'ils ont
plus de droits qu'elle commande dans les
détails on se rend compte que plus de
six éléments que l'on parle de
l'environnement puis justement j'ai fait
cet exercice la cglu les plateformes
j'ai suivi videmment j'étais impliqué
dans le développement de la recherche
pas derrière l'abc lectorale puis malgré
tout j'ai parce que ce pouvoir je
comprends mais mais sur l'environnement
c'est dans pas longtemps je te montre
considère ha je parle des enjeux de
l'environnement c'était pas mal on est
en jeu
évidemment tout le monde d'accord pour
avoir de l'art pour moi quelque chose
qui se modifie peu j'aurais pas à ta
question
je pense que plus largement on peut
parler de l'ange parce que je pense que
c'est important de juste réaliser que
toutes les parties proposent quelque
chose pour tous les ans je ne sais sur
pied puis j'ai des fois c'est à quel
point qu'ils en mettent l'emphase ou non
oui il est décidé à mettre l'emphase
un élément aussi on se lèche ou en effet
pour ce que les partis sont construits
comme plus compétents dans certains de
ces ingrats des fois c'est comme cela
qu'ils aient mère pour gérer l'économie
ce procès rouge en
partie ce qui est meilleur pour gérer
l'environnement j'ai perdu quelqu'un
qu'on regarde [ __ ] quand même raison
c'est l'environnement moi qu'est ce que
j'ai vu je pense que je suis mieux que
je ne le pense
mais
mais mais juste derrière des signes ou
ce que j'ai
les élections c'est pire que ce que je
faisais plus d'études électorale je me
rendais compte de l'importance de
l'enjeu de l'environnement justement
quel point ce que l'environnement
restait conséquent c'est sûr
[Musique]
que l'eau soit pas contaminé les âges a
passé le plus comme faut des matériels
pour survivre le thé la pyramide de
maslow le seul à la base puis quelque
chose qui s'est imposé c'est peut-être
un effet générationnel haut ce que les
jeunes c'est devenu comme un dangereux
que son identité
comme le l'enjeu le plus important pour
moi puis mon vote va être déterminé par
sa les parties sur quand même adapté
déjà
certains partis prendre en position sur
l'environnement mais oui
merci j'ai regardé les plateformes puis
je me dis à chaque fois les parties des
fois comme kaka par deux justement il
fut un match très dur et celles que la
la
comment les partis
sont compétents perçu comme composerait
la compétence perçus par des partis et
la cac qui son environnement on s'entend
tous je pense que c'est pierrick landais
comme les gens disent pourrait y laisser
quelques particuliers une meilleure pour
gérer l'environnement c'est rentrer les
gens vont à melaka que je crois que
personne de mise à niveau
comme ça mais mais quand on regarde leur
plate forme et ça c'est loin c'est jeudi
il parle d'environnement j'étais jolie
s'il était il parle d'un plan pour une
économie verte et ils veulent une baisse
de 37% jesse cgt comme le plq ses 45% le
pq aussi je pense 45%
les québec solidaire c'est beaucoup
moins 55% en
attendant les obstacles à partir
gouvernement à passer de l'accord la
carboneutralité ans pour 2050 la fin de
quelque chose qui ont déjà fait une
promesse la fin de l'exploitation que
l'exploration des hydrocarbures
et c'est comme il ya peu
la faim devant des véhicules est
l'essence bon sinon ils 30 2035 mais
c'est sa pépite et je suis c'est quand
même beaucoup le pij avoue que j'avais
des surprises c'est un peu ce que j'ai
regardé dans les plages qu'est ce qui
est surprenant qu est-ce qui est pas
question qu est ce qui rend pas le prêt
à temps
25 on peut le prendre la question parle
de ce qu'est ce qui rend pas pensé pour
toutes les parties dans le fond moi
c'est ça puis on peut on peut regarder
c'est comme ça mais tsepo pour
l'environnement particulier c'est
qu'après ça c'est vraiment une hypothèse
le cg le parti pour défaut tout à
l'heure je vous l'avais dit c'est
peut-être que vous êtes proche d'un
parti mais qui est plein d'autres
raisons pour voter pour ce parti avec
les gens
les croix pottoks au crotoy
nécessairement le tibet où il promet de
sonner pour les gens n'aient aucune
dating ce serait intéressant à voir mais
celui sur l'environnement certains
québec solidaire beaucoup beaucoup plus
loin at il par exemple la caq premier de
le développement de nouveaux barrages au
québec parizeau pertinents j'ai d'autres
raisons comme ça mais mais tous les
partis qui se distingue le plus au
lendemain c'est le véhicule ouais c'est
le pc culte c'est pas pour eux puis il
faut le voir de l'art angle de comac et
comment qu'il perçoit dispo non on veut
que la plaque la planète
seul angle le rang que le québec est un
enjeu international international puis
je dis que c'est pas ton sac de
plastique individuel il faut changer la
planète cgt comme son âge internationale
qui l'apport du québec je les défends
pas le jeu de la part du québec baisse
est minime et puis j'étais comme celle
up il faut pas oublier en tête lyon un
segment de la population qui peut
réfléchir de cette façon et que j'aurais
quand même aimé mais pour répondre aux
questions sur l'environnement ou est-ce
que si les parties sont plus il a
comparu avec jeux présents québec celle
d'un conte s'est aussi joint pas besoin
de le dire un peu plus environnementale
et ce avec le pq et le plq aussi a pris
position la cac mais tu vois qu'il
savait sûrement c'est sûrement je sais
pas que j'étais pas là mais je tenais
présent qu'il savait que c'est peut-être
un début de points un peu moins fort
donc mon cas j'ai vu la plateforme jeu
demain il y au moins en faisant un
effort conscient avec le pays que de
cette aide et se positionne en savez
quoi je vais aller les chercher les gens
qui hurle
mais gérée elle c'est drôle parce qu'il
met en mode c'est parce qu'on s'en va
top le must pour une cachette pour
personne vraiment le tuer mais je ne
sois pas voter pour eux puis sauf que
10 et leurs plateformes aussi il ya des
affaires que je capable de vraiment
vraiment bien comprendre le dire je me
rappelle à nous autres on est allé à
taiwan c'est anecdotique l' ultra
négatif parce que puis on donne à taiwan
perd mais on a pris le train de
l'aéroport jusqu'à taipei
le but c'est
qu'ils ont roulé à travers il s'appelle
le new taipei c'est comme une jarre de
ville encore plus grosse que taipei mais
comme industrielles puis je regardais
par la fenêtre puis je voyais mes temps
les toute l'espèce de
d'entreprise d'industrie puis de fumée
qui sortait par par les cheminées puis
jetée dans mon char de la bûche je me
disais c'est à fond cette can le
elle affecte la planète la même façon
qu'eux le gueux qui vole un oeuf
156 le jeu proportionnellement mais
l'environnement c'est vraiment un enjeu
international puis quand éric duhaime au
face à face il parlait de ce je me suis
pris à far cry semaine ça fait quand
même dix ans qui dit il puis moi qui
d'entrée de jeu je me dirais moi je suis
quand même environnementalistes suivait
gagnent pour l'environnement comme si je
prends toutes ces décisions là pour
améliorer plus après ce
si c'est pas 100% foot fait que tout
comme m6 aux autres non pas d'en tirer
que j'aime au face à face il expliqué
deans autre faux pas avoir été le voir
comme si on était les seuls à émettre
des gaz à effet de serre c'est puis
c'est vrai dans le fond les aixois est
valable c'est simple azotés l'argument
même qui dit si bennoo les combustibles
fossiles mais tant qu'on peut exploiter
un peu les ventes qui sont moins
polluants que d'autres utilisent mais
après ça c'est comme lui dit ce même
mois comment je vérifie si comme alors
c'est ça
c'est sûr elle peut-être plus la job
chemin des profs des journalistes
certaine c'est que ça résonne en partie
de la population qui à tort ou à raison
que je peux la comprendre des jugements
de valeur
se sentent un peu méprisé méprisé par
apport des foyers ont pas le choix tu
grandis on comprend pas la boîte au
début moi je viens de montréal j'étais
comme je sais c'est quoi la japd et ma
vie à dieu de lévis venue à montréal ou
à toronto
est radicalement différente quand tu
vois en région puisqu'elle ces gens
n'ont pas le choix de prendre la voiture
de cela on leur disait non a dit prendre
hôpital voiture il faut comprendre ces
gens là c'est ce côté là je vous dis que
mon mon principal souci c'est pas
partisan mon principal souci c'est la
pole à la polarisation plus c'est ça des
fois qu'il me fait pas les enjeux comme
ça puis autant d'un côté matisse mais il
faut qu'une sensibilisation qui se
développent chez certaines personnes
mais de l'autre côté foot rien
d'empathie qui se développe ou cdd mais
peut-être la réalité différente ou si la
réalité de vie est différent je peux
être que quelqu'un nous on leur fait la
morale
signalling 10 mai regardez là c'est pas
raisonnable la tgd votre truc le
changera rien c'est même pas
l'équivalent d'un grain de sable sur la
planète latine que vous me faites sentir
mal parce que je fais si j'étais si je
fais ça mais ces gens là peut-être qu'on
se radicalise et de l'autre côté donc
faut je crois qu'on a tous
on a tous travaillé la fin chacun d'eux
tout le monde sait on peut juste pas sur
les mêmes personnes des fois là dans
certains groupes chaque segmentation je
me vois que l'on parle de segmentation
puis avec tantôt d'une part les nouveaux
groupes sociaux de chaque groupe comme
ça qu'on y pense bon sens et ont chacun
leurs textes de turquie ont chacun et
puis à la fin ça m'a toujours marqué une
fois j'étais allé parce que je mets ta
j'habite québec puis je le disais je
vais aller visiter là bas aussi avec un
festival des boîtes quitter ça m'a
vraiment marqué avec quelqu'un comme
l'ancien vj de musiqueplus d'abus
81,6
[Musique]
intéressant le disco qui avait loupé
c'est moins certain que ça certes un peu
de mon régime alimentaire
des fascines intime on a joué comme
conduit vraiment encore de ma vie ne se
gère pas de voiture après avoir toussé
de cash déjà qu'il y en ait jamais eues
j'étais à montréal et à toronto avec
notre réalité que je sais j'en ai dit
nous on aime se veut ludique en
simultané de se fabriquer réparé
papapapa par les montréalais à pied
s'ils vont au café avec un tabac et
puis bien mais c'est exactement ça c'est
une autre réalité se voyait un
ressentiment et attendent un
ressentiment picchu et la butte de son
discours au ton micro kids était fille
carey nous y leurs pistes cyclables
important
nous on aime se brûler du gaz si notre
passion pour le droit de continuer de
s'appeler tuer les gens étaient ils
étaient polis crime à mobiliser parce
que c'est fois être sensible à cette
fois là je parlais de marketing d'aller
d aller écouter les jeunes s'intéressent
une façon d'écouter les gens des fois il
ya des trucs comme ceux qui sont assez
était dans la gauche la droite a évolué
beaucoup certains ont parlé j'étais au
cégep au chiffre du vieux montréal dans
le temps ou parce que il y avait le
sommet des amériques on avait là
puisque je parle d'être sayyaf mais est
inerte c'est pas vrai je mangeais pas de
souvenir je veux pas que déjà il ya des
gens qui m'écoutent pas que l'on doive
souvenez mais je sais qu'on dit souvent
il ya plein de raisons
mobilisés je me rappelle pas de la ligne
par rapport à l'environnement plein
d'autres causes c'était beaucoup la
mondialisation de la mondialisation et l
appui moi j'écoute et je l'écouté je
mets des amériques des autobus retourner
là bas avec les syndicats disaient je me
rappelle je pose la question mais
pourquoi puis moi j'essaie de toujours
des imprévus quotidien jamais la
mondialisation les gens abandonner plus
ensemble ces données plus international
vous pouvez pas quelque chose la demande
positif non compris on rappelle que les
les usines de jacques sont moins -
indiqué qu'ils ont pas d'autre
conclusion d'une culture syndicale mais
le son fait de mondialisation mais ces
six jeunes hommes vont déménager que
finalement ils vont perdre leur salaire
ils vont perdre leur maison
mais la culture syndicale et vous savez
quoi avec la mondialisation
je prenais que l'ami cela mais je pense
non pas mal raison à convaincre la
michodière déjà convoité des moquettes
chlorite qui ont voté pour 30 on peut se
poser la question est ce que c'est
vraiment le mur à laubadère vous
complètement aussi le fait que 30 dt
contre l'alena qui étaient contre
l'alena c'est ce qu'avance une position
classique démocrate la même façon
précipitée sur ces gens là qui ont
changé d'opinion mais ce ressentiment le
était arrivé il ya déjà comment
quelqu'un qui ont perdu leur maison et
déjà grands qui ont perdu leur job
peut-être ça puis jeudi comme une
certaine gauche
savane que certains des endroits cette
institution j'ai changé d'avis puis on
revient sur la gauche maintenant que ces
genres et on a ressenti n'en sont les
écoute pas mais peut-être mon vote ira
dans ce sens que ce
qui sera intéressant c'est que tout le
temps une raison pour le team et on
reprend l'exemple
c'est toujours une raison pour laquelle
les gens au du recensement où les gens
pensent que ni pense qu'ils
ont raison à noter objectivement et pour
les deux garçons pouvaient le faire - ça
serait mieux si un fake c'est non en
même temps
je vais acheter les avocats du diable
complètement là dessus mais si on peut
tout remettre tout le temps a
le meilleur relativiser à la fin on dit
amélie je veux que mes gars de par mon
festival s'est même pas l'équivalent de
journaux qu
ils peuvent peser et puis c'est une
question pierrick en commun qu on nous
répond à la question mais peut-être par
l'assesseur le complet mais c'est
celle à gaz qui est dépensé 40 et à la
tempête
exactement du billet d'avion et c'est
votre passion c'est ma passion
konami a
rien qui est qui
mais en fait j'avais demandé tu es
méthon
avant même d'y aller par un jeu et en
guinée
quelqu'un qui aucune d'été les partis
représentent quoi puis si tu ou si on
peut on peux tu faire un genre de
deux grandes lignes de ses coûts et les
valeurs mettons par six pieds ou est ce
qui situe justement sur les axes dès que
ça peut aider à comprendre le ton du
temps qui nous écouteront
des meilleurs classés pousse à rejoindre
des questions m'imposer je pense que la
cac et c'est du moins comme de
l'exposition était au centre de
l'échiquier politique
l'hypothèque
cgt rien enfin sciences politiques il
s'appelle l'électeur médian t elle
chercher celui qui trouve son public
emballé c'est le sens
de notre réalité au québec exactement le
même sens trahi je vous le disais que je
fais un autre pied avec un truc on a
discuté au départ c'est quand qu'on
parle de l'awb sélecteur jeudi dans ta
tout ce qu on le fait c'est tout ajouté
comme gauche droite asociale et gauche
droite économique au québec en plus de
femmes c'est vrai que pendant des années
des décennies
la principale c'est qu'on compare de
polarisation des pôles la principale
dimension ça a été les fédéralistes
souverainistes et pendant longtemps
c'est ce qui se trouve sur notre vote
ont gelé est ce que ces disparus moi je
ne crois pas en ce moment je pense que
ces disparus je pense qu'il eût été de
95 a aussi un effet générationnel on en
parle beaucoup moins que c'est beaucoup
moins saillants les jeunes pensent pas
nécessairement sauf que justement je
pense les jeunes seront peut-être moins
souverainiste les plus vieux mais ce
qu'ils sont plus fédéraliste je ne sais
pas je pense qu'ils pensent je suis
beaucoup moins instant je le sais
beaucoup moins important mais ça n'en
fait une dimension qui était leur
avancée a déclaré le parti québécois
d'un côté puis est parti libéral de
l'autre côté qui elle a vécu jusqu'à été
plus absorber un peu par la cac qui
essaie de défendre une position que dans
le temps les gens d indéfendables et l
autonomie ainsi noté entre les deux
c'est d'être impliqué dans sa marche
trois mois je me rappelle celle que
mario dit non ils se posent aux pattes
nappes sont en phase potable vous savez
quoi commence à se lever et non l'appel
de nationalisme c'est de dire regardez
on peut défendre le québec parce que
créer large partie de la population
ce constat québécois a récemment soulevé
aussi de la langue française de vouloir
plus de pouvoirs d'ottawa quand même
temps de faire notre truc sans faire de
référendum l'effectif de cette dimension
est encore l'offre si le pq
télé là dessus
le plq aussi une seule façon si ce n'est
pas départi 6 positionné 112 droite et
le pq de de rené lévesque avec pics
tweed lucien bouchard
je vais pas de marwa awad c est très
différent sur caen qu'on parle de
l'autre axe est ce qu'on arrive plus
commun que gauche droite économique
mais si je n'étais pas le même parti le
plq ça même chose côté jean charest est
prêt même chose que ses prédécesseurs
c'est venu du parti conservateur mais
progressiste conservateur au fédéral y
arriver des plus de droite économique
mais les gens qu'est-ce-qui ce truc tu
es réellement c'est est ce qu'on est en
faveur ou non d'un d'inde mais même pour
le référendum est un projet
structuré tout cas quand tu as compris
près de raison qu'il ya des chercheurs
est intéressé logiquement mon collègue
éric montigny là dessus de sauter cette
direction là un peu où c'était
effacement de sa dimension globale à la
perte de 6 ans j'utilise mes terme la
perte d'importance l'élément qui est qui
qui structurent notre
pensée au profit d'autres plus d'auge
droite mais le sait pertinement sont
retrouvés un peu perdu et qu'il ya
davantage que cet ange leur reviennent
sarr polarise sur cet ex m'est arrivé
quelque chose quand j'étais à la
maîtrise il ya eu deux manifestes on
oublie souvent je trouve que ce con mais
je trouve qu'on n'en parle pas assez que
nous avons marqué qu'un but et la
magnifique ce qui est un québec lucide
et j'attends d'eux c'est un magnifique
j'encourage ou du temps avec vous mais
moi je n'ai pas devant les yeux le met
mais vous allez lire
s'appelait pas mal de trucs par rapport
à la cac c'est un teint déjà préférant
de 95 ça va être dans les années 2000
2000-2006 de dans ce coin le commerce et
puis
c'est s'appuie avec je sais que c'est
moche à tatiana andré pratte et puis
avec joseph facal comment certains aussi
le désir des gens des ans ses ennemis
politiques sur l'axé sur l'axé
souverainiste fédéraliste
avancé puis sur leur sol et sur
l'économie des on peut utiliser un autre
truc faut que le québec avance pour un
québec lucide qu'on sorte un peu de ce
débat là on s'en va nulle part on parle
on parle de notre pouvoir au sein du
canada si tu avais fédéraliste notoire
des séparatistes network qui ont écrit
un manifestant nous allons se réveille
poitou se manifeste quand même le lier
directement faudra aller les voir le
lien direct avec le lac
léman la création
mellacois son ami québec mais en
réaction à ce il ya un autre groupe
de sortie un certain manifeste pour un
québec celle là en réaction à cette
vision québec je pense que françoise
david est pas mal lié à tout cela allez
vous en puis j'ai donné comme un peu
l'élan pour pouvoir lancer québec c'est
là qu'ils prenaient des forces
progressistes québec l'union des forces
progressistes
puis on utilise usa je m'appelle charest
maîtrise dans un coup avec alain et
inversement pour parler de ces du
manifeste le sait ça a pris du temps
mais j'ai l'impression que maintenant
quand je regarde si ces domaines fait
cela je me dise tu es comme un peu ça
montre un peu où il concerne à l'ipp ça
explique beaucoup de caisses qui se
passe en ce moment selon moi ça explique
quoi les deux anciens partis qui se
tiraillaient sur sur la question
identitaire
deux nouveaux partis sont arrivés en
portant ses idées au lieu de dire allons
de l'avant de cette façon une certaine
qu'on pourrait vraiment de manière très
simpliste que si vous allez les chacun
des bénéfices vous allez voir que c'est
pas aussi cadré que de la gauche très
simple et doit surtout de la droite
traditionnelle avait quelque chose sur
l'éducation que le
carré rouge à force on peut la claque à
prendre des positions un peu plus de
clics droite classique cet enjeu l'homme
était très très très court et concis de
gauche sur l'environnement au départ au
lancement mais ça a quand même été deux
parties que la caq met le cap sur belle
vie que le politique l'a vécu puis
accusé dans un communiqué des parties
plus mineurs puis avait le pq domine
avec le plq c'est vraiment c'est
finalement de cette taxe c'était comme
plus gauche droite économique
voudriez plus d'importance que tu pour
répondre à ta question justement c'est
auprès facilement des bengals
soit c'était la décrue
maintenant la 4g est vrai que c'est
vraiment aller vers le centre puis sur
tout le parti conservateur du québec
maintenant cub s'est déplacé de douane
et ensuite sur sur l'autre axe mais il y
en as mal fédéral fédéralistes ne voyez
que le plq la cac
le face à face c'est françois legault
qui est un ancien pour sur le plus les
plus jeunes qui sera l'appel pomme est
un ancien ministre péquiste qui écrit un
budget de l'an zéro d'un québec
indépendant télé le plus convaincu de
plus précis des souverainistes gamin
taille maintenant et comme fédéraliste
puisse avoue carrément fédéral explique
ren position par rapport à sa fille jada
au face à face et le pivot chercher
qu'est ce qu'il réalise on va d une
majorité de québécois quand même puis
se faire enlever la
fict et jeudi c'est un peu je trouve
qu'il est halal le débat est intéressant
parce que montrait qu' on est capable
que demandé mais m chacun des pôles sur
le sol dans les deux dimensions qui avec
un parti qui comme ceux plus centriste
qui va chercher peut-être les lecteurs
que ton après appellerez l'électeur
médian
cette méthode comprend l'accès mettons
le le plus les plus engagés en question
le mettons
que l'on parle de défense de france et
de l'indépendance c'est le pq
défense france one après je pense que le
la défense français c'est sûrement un
consensus parmi les partis qui va
prendre mais donc des mesures les plus
radicales mais les plus drastiques
drastique rapport à cet enjeu l'homme
qui vit seule on se rabat sur le bureau
de l'état que je parle tant que ses
drastiques dans ce sens je vais parce
que je pense que tous les partis ont la
francisation à car je pense qu'il ya des
partis qui croit plus à une intervention
étatique direct d'autres centres pense à
d'autres moyens d'y arriver les saints
que le pq puis je le savoure avec son
histoire la loi 101 genève acheteurs
il faut faire quelque chose puis il ya
une perception c'est de regarder le
qu'est ce qui se passe parce que c'est
pas vrai que les parties par contre la
plupart admettre les égards d'hélium il
ya des firmes problème vient des fils
vont un problème je li hao france et
surtout à montréal
mais mais c'est pas tout non plus la
population est déjà sur toute la
longueur du niveau fédéral j'ai comme
alexa des candidats n'ont rien pas de
problème je n'ai aucun problème le
réellement on regarde pas les bonnes
statistiques
mais les cinq partis que ce qu'il fera
je suis cependant que le fonds élections
au québec y sommes mais y admettre qu'un
magnifique un problème après ils
s'entendent pas sur la manière
puis peut-être que de l'urgence d'âge
est aussi c'est vrai que là dessus le pq
est sûrement celui kinder soit une
urgence plus important celui mettant
j'essaie juste de les placer mais ton
métier celui qui serait un peu sont en
guinée opposé du moins sur la question
de la souveraineté serait le plq qui lui
aussi sur la question des migrations sur
la casta question d'être un petit peu
moins interventionniste sur la question
du français on peut peut-être d'excès
l'ipc le parti libéral mais ce n'est pas
parce que ces deux enjeux de ce qu'on
parle de l'aspect de l'anglais en
particulier de france francis la place
de l'anglais ce couple de parents
certains
calculs c'est quand qu'on parle du
collège d'arras ou de l'accès aux cégeps
qu'elle pcq aussi inquiets qui feint que
c'est vraiment la faire une percée parmi
les anglophones qui est élément a
comparé de l'immigration ça dépend dans
quelle est encore qu on le voit et on ne
sait s'il faut des engeances ensemble
aussi télé est ce qu'on associe
l'immigration ou dickens france et est
seulement question pu m'éclater mais
mais mais
dans ce sens le québec solidaire c'est
ce qui va accueillir le plus
d'immigrants aussi en même temps sont
très
affirmée propres offerte aux français
mais vous voyez ça dépend de comment on
perçoit son est pessimiste ou optimiste
par comment est ce qu'on fait il voit
comme un enjeux d'intégration tenant un
espoir fera pas sûr qu'ils vont prendre
sérieusement en france exactement donc
c'est il faut pas faire trop d'amalgamés
comme cela les fois on en fait c'est
normal c'est norman est telle qu'un cc
puis je comprends c'est l'exercice est
impossible à faire le tri de de passer à
travers chacun des enjeux de cépie
sais quoi mais je prends de la question
différemment
comment on choisit pour qui on va t
comment choisir ce qu'on veut
parce qu'il ya trop de détruire une
formation que ce serait intéressant de
voir le fallait le quiz et se permet
même les cadres de sélection et 125 x 5
mai mais c'est vrai que si complexe que
certains éléments que l'on peut dans le
très avancé des pions c'est la gorge et
de penser ce qu'ils font on est surpris
mais après c'est ta question c'est
comment on choisit ou comment devrait
choisir de le truc répondons de ville
répondent en 2001 la théorie classique
la démocratie ce qu'on devrait
s'informer on avait réfléchi à l'avancé
on ne va pas avoir d'à priori trop
participants devraient prendre ce
vraiment c'est de manière froide nos
potes ne savais pas après c est ce qu
est ce que est ce que vous voyez pour
vous personnellement
ego
tréguier souhait ce que vous pensez à
l'ensemble de la société est-ce que vous
allez voter pour une hausse de vos
propres pose alors est ce que vous
devrez chacun devrait voter selon ses
propres leur poche le thé
c'est impossible mais ce n'est que dans
télé classique ce que l'on garde dont la
démo création on réfléchit tout
avec l'invention des sondages de menace
à 40 c'est le premier livre le plus
possible au
laser
prof en communication awards et de vos
instruments mais on s'offre la deuxième
guerre mondiale on va pouvoir maintenant
mesurer des sondages tout les lélés jeu
des influences avec tout le jeu
démocratique ça va être beau sortir
guerre mondiale
il y avait deux les à ses attentes des
citoyens la compétence citoyenne
l'intérêt politique sub saison d'âge
montre et canon les gens votent pas de
cette façon que sa deuxième question les
gens votre peau comme ça c'est ce qui a
été donné naissance à l'approché
sociologique des légendes your own site
quand on sait les gens votre beaucoup
commun qui ont été socialisés c'est
exactement sur cette approche où
justement le data ghachi a été fondé
c'est de dire regardez on est dans le
produit notre socialisation donc si vous
êtes catholique d'entente d'être
catholique blanc nez de tels états a été
saisie dans telle religion on est
capable de prédire votre vote parce que
ça a été socialisés de cette façon alors
deividas d'opinion dans votre groupe
vous faisait dans l'ordre opté après
s'il ya eu un autre éclat était
développée après coup à ce que rajouter
un peu plus donné mais s'en étant
l'aspect partisan ou est-ce qu'on
devient partisans on est socialisé au
départ dans toutes les variables que je
ne vous parle et en même temps
nécessaire faisait comme une équipe de
requins plus mais socialiser dans un
parti politique c'est surtout aux états
unis le républicain ou démocrate puis
ensuite si ce qui détermine perception
du cannabis qui n'était pas notre
personnel sur les anges moi je donne
souvent l'exemple à 1845 ce jeu c'est
raté de la charte des valeurs en
particulier quoi
magicien imaginez ça a été le parti
libéral qui a lancé la charte des
valeurs combien de puits qui s'était dit
en faveur puis combien de libéro
défaveur j'en aurais eu et c'est ce
qu'on va être vraiment seulement des
idées sont les va-t-il y en a il y en a
qui plus est lorsque yann et micro
public change d'avis oui mais à la fin
les gens votent beaucoup comme paradis
ou votre beaucoup par leur socialisation
puis regarde mais comment est-ce qu'on
devrait voter seront reclassés la
démocratie ce qu'on s'informe sur chaque
mise en jeu au pied comme des êtres
rationnels on comprend le choix qu'elle
meure pour nous mais maintenant ce que
c'est c'est compliqué parce qu'on ne
sait pas si c'est boulot ensemble la
société où c'est pour vous même ouais il
vous faut être capable de nous mêmes
fall espèce de hiérarchie des enjeux qui
nous importe le plus c'est simple on
rate là dedans
je travaille l'hétérogénéité des modèles
j'ai des commandes dans laquelle point
est ce que quelqu'un en jeu qui vous
touche vraiment personnellement
l'assaillant des enjeux individualités
quels enjeux de tunisie a chassé tel est
le
le l'environnement l'environnement est
seul dans les sondages c'est vraiment
difficile à mesurer le quand même je
mesure l'importance
que je vais le dire aux gens c'est quoi
qu'est ce qui est important pour vous
cela c'est la question que la série de
sondages c'est qu'elle fait pour ta pour
vous dont on met pas de choix de réponse
parce que l'on veut que ce soit le truc
qui essayant bataille mais ça un choix
des gens des gens que je
puisse aussi jeune étudiante camille
tremblay antoine qui fait sa thèse de
doctorat sur ce sera comment mesurer ses
parts dans des laboratoire de
psychophysiologie pressé de bourbon ce
que la question pour les mesures et ça
mais moi je suis convaincu que 410 cas
de mesurer ce qu'est l'enjeu qui est
important c'est comme un python faut que
chaque participant vient à la
segmentation
les échos le bouton de chacun des sept
mois pour faire changer le vote et non
faire changer la liste en verlan jeu
j invite à poser une autre question dans
le fond au lieu de décortiquer chaque
année les enjeux puis qu'est ce que je
propose
c'est intéressant de se poser la
question à qui chaque année participent
s'adresse ce que c'est peut-être que
c'est plus mettons là
dans le genre de données petit mettons
dans le genre de truc tu attaques de
type fusée c'est qu'ici qu'il ait publié
qui chacun des cinq pas si le thé mais
dont utiliser la base électorale
pour la base électeurs chacun des partis
ont une certaine base c'est le pq s'est
clairement les indépendantistes et
souverainistes
pizza mania c'est jacques roy a pigé
joreige organes mais cette affaire avant
car on regarde les sondages sur
l'indépendance mais si on n'accepte plus
élevé que la poubelle
26 fait donc c'est pas que c'est une
souverainiste d'un certain groupe dargis
que tout est très attaché à un parti de
mai ses 120 et figoureux parce que parce
que
les avaient pas l'artiste québécois
c'est pour un groupe homogène
des positions sur d'autres enjeux aussi
puis il faut vous s'assurer comme je
disais tout à l'heure que c'est un peu
trop disent car dans ce groupe club ça
c'est un des grands défis spicules ça
c'est certain ceux qui excellent dans
ses délires de saab à sa base est plutôt
urbaine plutôt chez les jeunes surtout
l'antique ans qu'on parle des clivages
au québec un bon bain au clivage entre
les graphiques le les dieux de 35 ans
québec solidaire a genre 88 ellul son
assesseur exactement les mêmes trucs
touré qui avec 125 les pros ni même sexe
était en faction et c'est la politique
fiction de cette façon mais c'est
intéressant ce qu'on se pose la question
mais donc qu'est ce que ça veut dire que
plus tard c'est ce qui va se passer pour
toujours faire attention avec c'est moi
je me rappelle je mens des piquets ce
qu'ils aiment regarder les gens sont
plus souverains escales 20 puis si on
vous sent plus en plus souveraine est ce
que les lieux tout se méfier des effets
générationnels mais des effets aussi là
où je suis je vieillis plus tu viens
conservatoire mais absolument on voit ça
un
étudiant à l'université il ya moins peur
du mail place par millions que quelqu'un
qui a fini sa
maison lui c'est à dire ceux qui
effectuent à la normale comme ça peut
saigner comme des effets générationnels
haussier qui restent sont marqués c'est
de faire une prédiction
précis je pensais bernard landry une
fois qu'ils avaient des vélos sont garde
ce sont les dépenses québec se
déterminent intime et
voudront faire attention ce que je dis
comme moi mais c'est certain qu'à ce
moment c'est un fait
c'est pas pour rien qu'il faut que
celles environnantes sont donc oui je
les adresse à leur base mais si leur
base ayant une base solide à posséder
l'a rejeté les pressions ou qui va jouer
au québec on sait déjà que c'est là dans
la région aussi québec même dynamique à
montréal
chacun sait pas le même québec 15e place
à michel c'est pas la même place a
annoncé sa fille du jeu dans tout ceci
était comme dit ma rivale de cette
nature l'homme et certains quartiers de
montréal pita pita québec puis je dis
justement dans le bas du fleuve
à gatineau en outaouais je laissais
d'autre part les mêmes participants 2011
en jeu donc qui stoppe les normands que
ça se passe comme ça mais certains que
la laque yves excédents avait réussi en
afin de percer le jeu tamar dans les
régions et surtout à québec genetic
catherine dorion
convoité leur positionnement quand je
regarde le positionnement disons par
exemple sur la loi 96 que je m'éloigne
de mon expertise pour amiens mais je dis
quoi mais je me dis mais peut-être que
le pot 4 1 service qui voit la loi 21
mai c'est l'idée c'est de pouvoir
peut-être allez-vous chercher un
clientèle poussines 4 chercher des gens
comme à laval où est ce que vous pensez
de croissance dans la dans ce coin là
que tu juges de son le voie de mer pour
moi
c'est un peu le peut-être
ou est-ce que ça en vaut maintenant jeu
pendant secret des dieux j'observe
qu'est ce qu'ils font c'est le plq
essayé positionnement comme si de rien
on va essayer d'aller chercher le
nationaliste
retourner les racines plus nationaliste
jusqu'en et non comme ça m'aidera à une
bourse aux divers tons evra qui récupère
et bree jean charest mais de si le
sabbat les anglophones llano partie
par surprise surprenant que de mon point
de vue le pcq courtisé ce vote là aussi
on était là-bas c'est cuit ce nouveau
parti c'est normal ce qu'il a dit ce
qu'il avait vécu passion beaucoup de
mars à partie quand même que dieu a
quand même qui parti de rien voulu
vraiment pas longtemps qui devenu
carrément des intentions de vote baum
probable mais non c'est ça puis c'est
nous qui est intéressante d'un point de
vue d'observateurs politiques c'est très
intéressant parce qu'au départ c'était
ça fait longtemps qu'il existe le parti
comme il y avait 500 mhz en
importance après que la pandémie ne
faudrait que plus personne n'en parlait
plus compliqué mais il va falloir
regarder c'est quoi les faits de ce truc
là je pense que dans dans la pandémie
une ciné spectacles qui s'est développée
durant ce temps là puis je dis comment
on a vu comme un double une espèce
d'anti élite tient un sentiment anti
élites commença à pipo juste au québec
le ton le vent on lui répond vous
risquez donc aux états unis je pense
cette base de ce que donnait comme un
peu le
truc là puy mary jane
fait preuve de jeu pas de flexibilité ou
ces deux postes se nourrir de ce jeu les
même pas entendu je pense parler de
pandémie je vis dans sa plateforme c'est
vrai les premiers pas si noir quelque
chose d'une réglementation pour empêcher
la vaccination forcée dans le fait tous
les ans
personne ne veut entendre parler des
sols dans les 20 minutes par chef de
radio canada day prudence minutes qui
apparaît quand même beaucoup de la
pandémie je pense beaucoup plus question
de tergiverser aussi mais c'est sa
puissance et quand un des trucs mais je
déconne
on est comme ça les gens vont vouloir
mois par l'était il ya pris des
positions donc moi je n'ai jamais parlé
avec des amis
sur moi je prédis qui vont se
positionner sur la sur le pétrole parce
que là je voyais fait à la scène
bastille moi c'est lorsque puis encore
une fois je prendrai ce qu'il est dieu
dans l'autre des parties mais mais quand
je regarde le parti conservateur du
québec je me mets dans leur sous l'isin
l'apatite sinistrés dans les slips
qu'est ce que je ferais moi si je
voulais comme est large et ma base young
boys mais cette série une base de gens
qui sentent pas écoutés ex ante mais
crise de façon si je pense que on a
parlé tout à l'heure cette base de 100
ter ou fertile ces gens-là ce qu'ils
votent ski votre pote c'est beaucoup de
monde qui loge les oueds anecdotes cycle
à la télévision sa première fois je vais
voter on va le voir c'est en bonne voie
on sait pas mais mais par contre un truc
est certain c'est que la caq que c'est
de se positionner au centre service un
espace quand même plus à droite puis ces
gens là tout comme la relancer
l'ancien terreau fertile delà des cuts
des gens qui veulent moins d'impôts des
gens qui veulent des positions plus de
droite affirmé déjà qu'ils sont
peut-être moins environnementalistes
mais c'est que ces électeurs là il ya
les verts le parti qui était le plus à
droite qui paie comme lala 4000 en ce
moment si on garde ses lecteurs à l'afp
si si je me mettais dans leur saoul il
vraiment été offerte il serait ou même à
l'ancien fief de la b q est ce qu'elle
est le succès ou
l'ami pierrot direct sur tlm a semé des
tickets t mettons legault se fait
tellement talent de nice en plein de
questions par les particules sont plus à
gauche que lui qui tendrait se défend et
non l environnement est important pour
moi puis tandis que l'autre il fait
juste mal pétrole joie on va aller
chercher le thé lui c'est comme
complètement fictive quand même dix
faits reprochés quand même se fait
talonner de la sutie vsb wii rouge pour
de vrai le troisième liste pour on va
attendre les études c'est on va le faire
quand on les laissait sur ces éléments
je trouve que je trouve quelques jeux
dans le point de vue politique
stratégique et il prend des poussées qui
certains réalisent certaines personnes
seules à lyon une bonne bonne balle aux
coqs qui épie en plus ça attire
l'attention aussi les positions qu'ils
savent un peu
on en parle plus un petit parti je vais
fouiller un peu de temps là la chance de
se faire entendre au temps qui appuiera
parti pris finalement être plus que sait
on en parle beaucoup le truc par contre
personne ce pc qu'il y ait des trucs
quand même surprenant et puis je vais
regarder ça puis j'espère - peut-être
que les deux personnes suivis on a
chacun nos informations tout ça mais moi
qui avait des trucs qui m'ont surpris
c'est le transport en commun gratuit
voilà québec ça sort du prêt à penser ça
le 8 février le tramway aussi au québec
le trait moi je sais pas c'est quoi sa
position par consensus t on le fait on
le fait c'est très mou et peut-être
deschamps n'a pas de passé impliqué là
dedans mais quand je regarde les
suppositions sur l'espace a été prise
publicité la
finance et plus d'un dans les
infrastructures sportives
quand je regarde la liste des 120
premiers jo un sommet sur la santé
mentale des jeunes déjà on a demandé aux
gens
le pcq pense que c'est pour tout le
temps comme ça qu'il faut faire
attention on ne peut donc pas rentrer
dans les dessins forme idéale et les
plateformes de chacun averti que sinon
on rendre puis on met des caricatures ça
se passe à gauche se passait à droite
c'est cependant sur vanessa se passe en
effet des rallyes tout le temps on fait
des associations rapide à l'examen c'est
tranquille donc et la même façon une
fois que le canada anglais m'ont fait la
même chose que les québécois ils font ce
donc c'est via la banane enfin c'est ce
mois mais chaque fois que l'alabama et
elle est moins rude
que je peux souvent les gens c'est de
réfléchir je joue l'avocat du diable
pour que les gens arrêtent de rentrer
dans le trait à penser puis qu'on
regarde vraiment les plateformes des
partis continuent d'être la caricature
mais c'est intéressant c'est qu'on
vienne pas puis pour quelqu'un béton qui
serait de l'autre côté du spectre qui
verrait mettons q est-ce comme un parti
radical y est eu des surprises dans le
sens des choses vécues s peuvent me
propose qu'on aurait dit qu'on n'aurait
pas pensé y mettons qui
en effet puis je vais je peux rester
comme c'est drôle parce que je ne sais
pas si j'avais vu où c'est moins qu un
et flasque ont rassemblé dans cette rue
club j'essaie de trouver des surprises
pour chacun des partis c'est vrai qu est
ce un moins de surprise c'est quand même
plus un certain péter un petit peu plus
un parti de gauche classique je pense
que peut-être la surprise puis ce fut
une surprise pour ceux qui soit
peut-être moins la la la politique mais
si c'est prêt c'est très le libéral en
ce sens philosophique les traîtres et
les libertaires par rapport à ce qu'est
ce qui est social s'est choisi un
certain que tout cas ce qui est qui et
qui lit dont à la francisation mais
aussi quand quand je regarde les aussi
la position sur
ce
départ des marches tout j'ai dit comme
ça c'est le titre de trucs que je me dis
si on veut aller chercher les
progressistes anglophones c'est
peut-être un peu plus mais je mets
vraiment l'homme un peu leurs patates
chaudes cette question parce que y'a
parle pas trop à moins qu'il fasse poser
la question j'ai l'impression pis s'ils
ont quand même un bon appui c'est quand
même dans les flots de filles
multiculturelle c'est mais en même temps
ce n'est pas populaire chez les
immigrants tant que ça mais c'est
exactement le sait exactement alors que
je me dis mais c'est pour les gens qui
regardent observe la
politique québécoise ont été surpris on
distille on se rappelle la fusion avec
option nationale t on en même temps
c'est vrai que ce septet ça réduit
peut-être un peu leur potentiel de
croissance quand je vous dit tala pour
toute la région de laval depuis les
anglophones le voter immigrants à quel
point ce qu'on peut certains ont narré
des gens ici comme du québec celle d'ap
nous l'expliquera matri je sais que sa
carte pas dans les trucs je disais comme
il
va falloir plus d'explications que plus
d'explications mais cela va quand même
même la réponse
de gabriel dubois lors des entretiens
c'était quand même pour moi c'est confus
exactement qu'est ce qui va le faire par
rapport à un référendum c'est que nous
irons faire un référendum mais sur
ce qu'est ce que ce serait la
souveraineté vers 10 et qui sait que
c'est quand même je me regarde
d'expliquer c'est quoi exactement leur
place de mémoire tg lui le plateforme de
ce puits de mémoire ça me rappelle
beaucoup le je t'aime à la plate forme
d'obsaar nationale je pensais à venelles
au delà c'est comme une idée de
développer une constitution avancée de
poser enfin référent dauphin référendum
on va constituer un projet de société
qui serait pas un indépendant ce jeu
c'est l'indépendance pour l'indépendance
totale indépendance s'ils ont un projet
de société qui va évidemment et
progressistes fille mais quand où est ce
que toutes les parties vont avoir leur
mot à dire les minorités et micros les
autochtones tous ces gens là vont avoir
leur mot à dire et ensuite mais comment
un peuple ce médecin à référendum puis
c'est un peu lead-in de l'un et de
l'autre après c'est certain cette patate
chaude sur le français aussi de la loi
météo ils sont repositionnés cgeci de
chercher l'information mais ça aux
poussines et je pensais les plus
libéraux pas encore une fois de manière
philosophique sur la question tg ue
qu'est ce que j'ai compris le puits il
souffle et celle d'arrivée - ch et en
mai mais même source c'est plus juste de
permettre aux enseignants de rodez
signes religieux mais aussi les juges
les pôles si j'étais restée rachètera ça
c'est vraiment fou seulement s'ils se
sont comme débarrassé peut-être d'une
patate chaude thomas pour ceux qui
aiment pas un pré réservations chez les
progressistes immigrants ou anglophones
mais par contre la loi 96 c'est et on va
t'es beau puis ils disent mais c'est
juste le 6 mois changé ce n'est pas bon
non mais mais c'est ça mais ces gens
mais c'est juste le 6 mois mais quand
même la francisation comme ceux d'une
manière perçu le thé gamin quand forceps
mais c'est peut-être l'élément cannes -
qu'une espèce de gauche progressiste je
voudrais classique anglo saxons c'est
dur d'être l'été on dirait qu'ils
veulent un peu le bob la chance par la
sacem et ses environs on veut 80 mille
migrants mais on veut que sont les
français
c'est très important pour ça parce que
mais c'est ça maintenant vous voyez ça
dépend de pc lorsque c'est des questions
empirique mais c'est quoi les moyens de
ses prises mais c'est pas grave je le
sais mais on arrive à avoir les moyens
qui leur permettent d'être assise et
mais ils vont venir vers nous pouvons
être contents d'apprendre le français
puis soit c'est une question est-ce que
c'est lyon reste je ne sais pas
oui je sais mais ça c'est des éléments
mais pour la cac la carte des trucs je
l'avais dit halak mots comme surprise
sur l'environnement je sais je trouvais
qu'on n'en parle pas assez loin après ça
j'ai l'impression qu'ils ont tellement
souffert mais disent l'environnement là
les derniers mois qui se répondent et
qu'on lit c'est comme ça car il pourrait
donc on dit qu'on leur résiste pas mais
par contre c'est ce lundi que conseiller
dans les bacs dans les derniers mois
quand je regarde moi je dis deux coups
ce les maisons le kanak au canada le
titre comment avertie elle tolère
j'étais raciste et
puis mais par contre sur les langues
autochtones sont tassées ces gueules
valoriser ils veulent permettre ayant
des promesses pour aider les autochtones
heures à valoriser leur longue à
développer l'apprentissage des langues
autochtones ça aussi c'est un peu
spécial - comment une aussi attend quoi
ça n'attend pas ce pôle sa carte pendant
le prêt à penser justement il faut four
réfléchis tu m l'horloger devient 2 août
sur piano une voix absolument mais ça
saccade pas encore qu'est-ce-qui
conventionnel dans quels sont tes
habitudes réfléchir loin
pour voir qu'on arrête parce que parce
que ça va être en relais fait un bon
bout pipi c'est dans cela mais je veux
quand même de poser une question parce
que qu'ils parlaient d'eux on a parlé de
cynisme tantôt puis une des choses qui
crée le cynisme surtout j'imagine pour
le notre génération c'est qu'on a
l'impression que une campagne fera de
même ce n'est que des promesses non
c'est pas aussi c'est quoi qui réussit
côtier qui fait c'est quoi qui parfait
puis un autre de tes projets permet de
voir quelles promesses ont été remplies
peux tu nous parler un petit peu ouais
c'est ça c'est un projet que ça c'est
pas ma création par rapport aux
touristes que j'étais vraiment impliqué
dans la conception de l'elysée c'est un
outil qui a été développée s'appelle
poli m s'est développée par un des
chercheurs d'os laval dont françois
pétry puis cac a pris sa retraite mais
j'en accueillir des faits puis que j'ai
on obtient 17 mon but c'était comme de
pouvoir peut-être le fait l'aspect plus
visuel ce pour que ce soit le plus
accessible que ces semences en tout les
progrès dont parle ce transfert de
connaissances puisque l'utilisation du
numérique pour aider à au transfert de
connaissances que bref le pot limit mais
qui fait entrer à voir avec vox pop
l'axé comme la boussole électorale
mais si on regarde les promesses c'est
cette expérience soit un groupe de
chercheurs qui détermine jusqu'à jeudi
de conceptualiser c'est qu'une promesse
et compromettre ce qu'antoine premier
souffre mais bon on regarde les
plateformes on élabore des promesses et
ensuite quelqu'un devant quelques élus
m'ont suis ton suis vraiment l'art
l'état de réalisation de la promesse
l'on regarde recherché plein de
documents c'est beaucoup beaucoup c'est
fastidieux beaucoup de travail mais le
but c'est justement c'est pouvoir voir
la transparence démocratique pour un
monde ait accès à cette information le
moussem honnêtement surpris quand je
tiens juste à les voires mettant
justement le juste le résultat de la cac
si moi je m'attendais à ce que les
promesses soient jamais rempli et
j'aurais même rappelé la promesse
oui c'est cela et on va en plus leur
première ce type i jean la grande c'est
une minorité des premiers s'ils ont été
laissés dominer s'est laissé de côté une
majorité des premières rampes lippi le
reste c'est des promesses
si elle me remplit maintenant mais ça
m'a surpris à quel point ils ont fait ce
qu'ils ont dit que c est important de
mentionner que de le répéter aussi ce
que je pense que c'est plus facile
jusqu'aux peut-être notre nature quand
on est avec les lions en aidant les plus
négatifs en général très positif meetic
oui les gouvernements remplissent plus
leur promesse qu'on pense puisque j'ai
communiqué on peut regarder mais par
contre elle peut le mettre une de ses
faiblesses le souhait que l'on travaille
aussi si on parlait de sai ans
d'importants des enjeux aussi ce jeudi
comme de réparer plus n'importe quoi le
métier de réparer l'année d'une statue
spa même chose que faire la réforme des
modes de scrutin
mehdi s'est mis un peu sur le même pied
de guerre ils font partie sont il va
falloir pondérée pour cette importance
là ça fait partie de mes travaux ça fait
partie mais mes objectifs d'aller dans
cette direction là mais ça reste quand
même que quand on regarde ses petits on
y voit ses îles et pitons réparer le nez
de
l'état et à la fin c'est le périmètre
regarder même par les papas les gens
tout quand on a menti puisque les faux
électeurs savaient que nous expliquions
on essaie de voir
nous des preuves ce que c'est un travail
quand même fait pour la démocratie puis
après on peut comparer ou c'est dans le
temple en cas de vol donc c'est normal
que des gouvernements qui était
minoritaire c'est plus difficile de
police tente raisons premièrement
rémunérateur dure moins longtemps donc
moins de chance - t'as pour réaliser les
promesses nées deuxièmement aussi sont
moins responsables parce qu'ils sont
obligés de phase ii
x6 mais des négociations avec les autres
partis politiques donc ça dit lui un peu
leur programme c met ceux ci les
citoyens regarde mais le plus important
c'est ça soit ouverte les gens puissent
regarder ce faire leur jugement m entre
cynisme ce que le cynisme pour le
cynisme depuis tantôt je parle du prêt à
penser mais c'est ça aussi c'est ça
aussi c'est facile d'être ce n'est plus
toujours critique toujours mais à la fin
il ya des gens tu as peut être moi vous
qui se présentait pour un parti et puis
à la fin c'est vraiment vraiment une job
très ingrate et on en a besoin on en a
besoin de ces gens là puis justement si
les gens vont les les plateformes
électorales cas parce qu'il ya des
outils qui les aident à 6 retrouvez mais
c'est cela c'est dès qu'on commence à
s'intéresser à petit le plus difficile
c'est de briser la glace de commencer
vous le savez vous savez la politique
des conventions presse commun de cyril
on les connait pas lesquels et les
personnages c'est dur de rentrer dans
une série vous apprennent un petit peu
c'est pour ça que je pense le secteur de
target chip ceux des trucs qui peut
être allumé un peu un intérêt politique
une fois qu'on commence comme ce qu'on
regarde on se rend compte que c'est
peut-être ce là la mère recettes pour le
cynisme c'est l'information petit une
saison à tous on a tous une mission otan
mois comme professeur comme chercheur
qui dorment intervenant dans l'immédiat
que vous
de votre podcast
mon moteur de maîtrise dans treize
thompson écrit un essai qui s'est libéré
d'un sexe sur kamal à la politique pour
devenir aussi addictif que des drogues
tombe dedans mais dont
on remette le lien en fait vers la
boussole vers le data goetschy
dans la déception qu'on invite les gens
à s'informer
puis à aller voter le 3 mai merci
beaucoup c'est merci alain pour
l'instant merci merci